there's going to be things in your life
that you don't have control over human
beings can control a lot more than they
think they can and oftentimes it's
pretty easy just to say oh that's not me
that's not on me and people say that's
not my fault there's nothing i can do
about that and more often than people
think there is something you can do
about it and it is your fault
chucklewood link welcome to the show
thanks for having me appreciate it
you flew to watch the ufc with
cam haynes and chris pratt
i want to know what a night out with
jocker willink looks like
well actually i didn't fly up there with
cam cam was already up there i think he
flew in from oregon where he
is where he lives
but we did we did meet up there and but
i did fly up there with chris pratt and
jack carr
and some of the other folks from the
terminal list which is a tv show that
chris pratt is in
that jack carr wrote the book that the
show was based on
and we went up there watched the fights
it was it was a very cool night yeah it
was fun
what time did you get up the next day
i got up
i don't know but cam was giving me a
hard time he says what you know what are
you are you gonna get up tomorrow
morning and i said i'm not even gonna
get home until three in the morning and
that's right that's when i got home i
got home at three o'clock in the morning
i think i got up around
maybe eight eight thirty something like
that
the fact that you don't do the 4 30 a.m
thing after a night out makes me feel at
least a little bit more mortal
if it's gonna be less than four hours of
sleep then i'll make some kind of
adjustment
you'll just push it the next day yeah
what was it like to see the ufc live
have you seen that before i've been to
so many ufc's i don't know i don't know
how many ufcs i've been to but i've been
to a lot i spot i
when i was younger i spent a lot of time
coaching and training fighters so i'd
corner i've cornered a bunch of fighters
in the ufc and so i've been to i don't
even know how many ufcs i've been to but
i haven't been in a long time i haven't
been in probably three four years
so it was cool to go and see one again
and and get back up there ufc
seeing the ufc live is is awesome and
look you know people will say and even
i'll say this too it's great to sit at
home
and
you know get all the different angles
and hear the commentary
that's cool there's there's a benefit to
that but there is a lot of a lot of hype
and a lot of energy that that's in the
room or in the in the stadium when it's
going on and so being there live
definitely definitely is is is worth
doing
occasionally to make sure you don't
forget what that what that's all about
how do you handle the next day now if
you've had a few drinks the night before
i actually don't drink so uh you know
that's really no factor for me
you know i i drank a i drank more than
my fair share when i was in the military
and then when i retired from the
military and i kind of just
over time over
over time i just kind of wasn't drinking
anymore now i just don't really drink
anymore there's not much in it for me
you know i'm a i'm an old man with i'm
married with kids and businesses and all
this other stuff going on so i'm not
going to get much out of out of drinking
anymore and a big price to pay the next
day as well if you did decide to do it
maybe
i guess i i
sure i guess that that might be some of
it but
there's just i just don't i'm not
getting anything out of it so two of the
biggest elements in your life have been
your military training and your martial
arts training
what would you say are the commonalities
between the best bjj athletes and the
best special forces operators that
you've worked with
there's uh probably the
the biggest commonality between the two
is
some kind of strange contrast between
being extremely disciplined and being
extremely creative
so clearly if you're going to get good
at jiu-jitsu you got to be the you got
to be disciplined enough to train all
the time same thing with being in the
military if you're going to be a good
operator you have to have the discipline
to push yourself in training but you
can't be a person that
you know leans so hard towards a
disciplined structured life that you
don't have any creativity because
both in jiu jitsu and on the battlefield
you want to
you definitely want to have
be creative and figure out creative
solutions and things that people haven't
thought of and things that the enemy is
not going to think of or that your
opponent's not going to think of so you
got to find that person who has a good
balance between
discipline and
kind of a wild freedom creativity that
they can make adjustments
it's interesting to think that
more focus or more efficiency isn't
always the solution to everything
so i
the
analogy i'd use is
if you think about an artist's
creative studio where they need their
creativity
it's not orderly you know there's
half coffees and easels and sketches and
paint and all sorts of stuff all over it
what does that engender what's that
environment creating for them but then
when they need to go and file their
taxes trying to file their taxes in that
same room is
probably not a good idea and i guess
that flip-flop between off and on right
between focus and play
it seems like a very interesting thing
to think about especially in a military
context what what does that mean when
you're talking about a special forces
operator being creative
you know there's a certain level of
inside the military in general is if
you're gonna
you have to be a person that kind of
follows the rules
and stays within standards and that's
great and you're gonna you're gonna be a
good solid
soldier if that's what you are
but
if you have a mindset that's very that's
so highly disciplined and so highly
structured like i just said then you're
not gonna think creatively when there's
a problem that needs to be solved so you
want to have people that don't mind the
discipline and can actually access the
discipline in a way that they can
utilize it but you don't want people to
be trapped by discipline and it's the
same thing in jiu jitsu if you have
someone that only knows how to do a
certain move
and they can't think creatively about
other ways to employ that
it's not that they're not going to be
good because they are going to be good
but there's gonna they're they're gonna
reach limitations and you know one of
the interesting things in the seal teams
is
we didn't have
especially when i was coming up we
didn't have any doctrine whatsoever
there was no there was no written
doctrine of any kind so everything that
you learned was word of mouth you
learned from the guys that went before
you and that meant if the guys that went
before you weren't didn't really know
what they were doing you're probably
learning a bad way and if you didn't
think
if you didn't think objectively about it
then you might follow someone down a
path that doesn't make any sense
so you ended up with a bunch of guys in
the steel teams that were pretty
open-minded and they could kind of look
at problems and figure out how to solve
them in the army and the marine corps
they
have
doctrine for just about everything this
is how you do a raid this is how you
conduct an ambush they had written
doctrine for this so if you didn't know
how you could just look at a book which
is actually a huge benefit for them
because if i'm a new platoon commander
and i
don't know how to do an ambush i can
just look at this book and i can learn
how to do it and so there's some huge
benefits to not to to having a very
disciplined doctrine that you can follow
but
that's one of the
odd advantages of the seal teams is that
since we didn't have any doctrine we had
to be a little bit more free thinking
and that made us a little bit more
adaptive in in some situations so it's
just like anything else your strength
can be a weakness your weakness can be
your strength and you have to be aware
and if you're aware that it's a strength
and if you're aware that it can also be
a weakness and if you're aware that it's
a weakness and you're aware that it can
also be a strength then you can probably
optimize the way that you're going to
think which is pretty beneficial do you
think that can be trained that
creativity
yeah i think creativity can be trained
it just like any other
natural trait
some people are going to have more
propensity to be creative than someone
else and some people are more rigid than
other people in the way they think and
you can take someone that's more rigid
and you can make them more creative
but everyone's gonna have some kind of a
limitation and some people
might have a pretty pretty pretty
subdued limitation of how creative
they're gonna get and some people can
really be trained to get a lot better at
that where did you fall on that spectrum
i would say i fell
i would say i fell pretty hard in both
directions so i i i was you know a
disciplined person that believed
instruction i liked structure and at the
same time
you know i was
i i would definitely think of things in
a different way and i i was a very
rebellious kid and i think rebellion
could be somehow tied to
creativity and looking at things in and
saying hey that doesn't make sense to me
so
i'd say that i had a i'd say it was
pretty
a pretty strong degree of both of those
things and that's what made me who i am
well especially the music that you
listen to as well growing up right i
don't think
almost all of the kids i know that grow
up listening to metal or hardcore
they've you can't listen to that and not
have a rebellious streak in you yeah you
definitely can't listen to that and not
have a rebellious streak in you and that
that's that
that did kind of drive my way of
thinking a lot when i was growing up and
and not only did it drive my way of
thinking i think i found that kind of
music because that's the way i was sort
of
engineered in the first place so
yeah who are you listening to when you
grew up
bad brains black flag agnostic front
crowmags
black sabbath is my favorite band of all
time
yeah those kind of bands
a lot of your work is
it's focused on encouraging people to
take ownership and responsibility for
things one of the things that i've been
thinking about a lot recently is whether
it's possible to take too much
responsibility or too much ownership
where you
start to believe that you're at fault
or you're accountable for things
and blame yourself
too frequently blame yourself too much
you think that's possible
there's a way that it can happen
usually from a leadership perspective
when people ask me this question
hey can is it possible to take too much
ownership the answer is yes and that is
if i'm in charge
and you're working for me
and i take so much ownership over a
mission or over a project that you don't
feel like you have any input at all then
i've taken too much ownership
as far as as like as an individual
person
there's going to be things in your life
that you don't have control over
and uh
you know one of the one of the early
questions that i got asked about this
you know like for instance someone gets
a terrible disease
and
you know or their kids gets gets a
terrible disease
a random disease that's
through no fault of anyone
the kid gets sick or the person gets
sick and no there's nothing you can do
about that what you can take ownership
though is how you respond to that
situation and so that's what you have to
do there's things that you can control
there's things you can't control now i
will tell you that
human beings can control a lot more than
they think they can
and oftentimes it's pretty easy just to
say oh that's not me that's not on me
and
i think that's that's the whole genesis
of the idea of extreme ownership is most
of the time or much of the time people
say that's not my fault there's nothing
i can do about that and
more often than people think there is
something you can do about it and you
can and it is your fault
i i i find it interesting to think about
uh it's not your fault but it is your
responsibility as well
and and how that sits in amongst this
my concern with it is don't get me wrong
i think that right now the vast majority
of people need to take more
responsibility i think that it is a
great counter to a victim mindset i
think that it helps people with agency
and sovereignty
i can see elements in my life though of
times when i've blamed myself for things
which
i'm in no way even remotely associated
with so for instance let's say that i'm
doing a podcast with someone or or i'm
doing a live event right i'm
facilitating some discussion and i ask a
question and the guest fluffs the
response like
gives a poor response a lot of the time
the first place that i would go is that
was on me somehow i should have asked a
better question
and even if i'd asked the absolute
perfect question and you could roll that
forward into a relationship you know
that you're in a relationship with a bad
partner or you something something
occurs
i just i'm trying to find that line
of how people can balance it so that
they don't end up
putting so much pressure and weight on
them that it crushes them yeah well
here's two examples of what you're
talking about
you you mentioned one relationship
another one is just if you're working
for me so if you're working for me and
you
don't show up on time or you're not
professional when you're conducting your
briefs
i need to say something to you and i
need to take ownership of the fact that
i haven't made it clear that hey you
need to show up on time and hey you need
to be more professional and hey you need
to wear the right uniform or or dress
the part
i need to take ownership of that
and maybe if i do and i talk to you and
we discuss why it's important and you
say i really didn't think about that and
you change your ways and you get on
board and you start showing up on time
you start acting more professional it's
great we solve the problem
there's also a chance that you're late
again or you show up you know with with
booze on your breath or whatever and
we're meeting with a client and i say
hey chris you can't do this this is
look i'm serious
you cannot act this way this reflects
bad on all of us and maybe and i might
even say listen if you keep this up
you're not even working here anymore i'm
gonna have to get rid of you you say i
know i love working with you it's gonna
be great i won't do it again and maybe
that solves your problem or
maybe you're late again or you continue
to act on professionally then i'm gonna
get rid of you i'm gonna say hey chris
look i talk to you i try to explain this
to you
and at a certain point i this job isn't
for you so that can happen and i i have
to take ownership of the fact that you
are actually not capable of doing this
job that i've asked you so that's fine
same thing can happen in relationship
right
look if you're in a relationship with
someone and you're bickering about
where we're gonna go for dinner or you
came home late from work and all you do
is well i've been working all day you
should respect the fact that i've been
working on it like that's that's
actually on you that's actually on you
and you can make adjustments to that now
can you get to a point in relationship
where the other person is
not a good fit for you and at some point
you say you know what i've made these
adjustments i've come home you know on
time i've texted you when i was going to
be late
and these these other things are coming
up and you say you know what i don't
think this is working and i don't think
this is a good relationship so at a
certain point you say okay i've made the
adjustments that i can make and i have
to take ownership of the fact that we're
not a good match
so
yeah there's there's plenty of times
where
taking ownership means actually solving
the problem not continuing to
to pour the problem down your neck every
night because that's not very helpful to
anybody so yes at a certain point
you have to you have to make adjustments
and you have to move forward
there's a lot of similarities i think
between your personal philosophy and
jordan peterson's i know you've spoken
to him a couple of times what have you
learned from him
well the the most interesting thing that
i learned from jordan peterson and i
mentioned this the first time he came on
my podcast was that
you know he's a trained academic that
studied this stuff his whole life and
we came to a lot of the same conclusions
about things and i just came to those
conclusions through
living and the experiences that i had
and he came to them through studying
this stuff in a very rigorous way
and and the cool thing is luckily for me
i had written books that sort of
predated uh i got there first yeah i got
that first it wasn't that i got there
first but
i mean
this these were the thoughts that i had
i mean discipline equals freedom that
book came out i think before i before
jordan peterson was on the scene it's
the book extreme ownership which is
about taking personal responsibility
what's about taking responsibility and
you can definitely apply it to personal
responsibility
so luckily for me those those books kind
of predated uh jordan peterson
coming onto the scene and
and doing everything that he did but
again it's not like i created any of
those things it's not like i created it
before he created and it's not like he
created it before
other philosophers had figured these
things out
so
i'd say the most interesting thing about
jordan peterson that i that i found and
i think it was pretty interesting to him
too was the fact that we both had kind
of come to these same conclusions and we
had lived very different lives i mean
i'm sure there's
more disparate lives that we could live
but they're pretty different lives
and
that's that was a very interesting thing
and it made me feel like
well it made me feel good about the fact
that the things that i had figured out
were in line with things that he had
figured out and that means maybe there's
a little bit more strength and
universality to these things that i
believed which
which felt pretty good
just gonna pause that do you wanna go
and see if there's someone stealing
things outside
if there's someone stealing things can
you let me know
it looks like they're bringing things in
that's the opposite
it's nice to know or to think that
something that's been proven in the
field of battle or on the field of play
is backed up in academia right that
someone can go through the annals of
philosophy history and come to a similar
conclusion as you yeah uh absolutely and
you know the stuff the stuff that i say
is in the bible the stuff that i say is
in stoicism and and
jordan peterson you know says the stuff
that i say or i say the stuff that he
says again i'm not
trying to compete with jordan peterson
on any level
especially some kind of an intellectual
level but
we have
similar thoughts about things and that
predated either one of us knowing who
each other were so i think that's pretty
cool
why do you think people are drawn to
advice that's telling them to do hard
things
kind of seems counterintuitive
why do i think people are drawn to
advice telling them to do hard things
because i think p any
person any human realizes that if you
want some kind of a good outcome you're
gonna have to work hard for it and if
you and if you don't work hard for
something you're not going to get an
outcome that's really worth much
well that is
the thing
that separates the achievements on the
other side of it right if it was easy
everyone would do it if it was even easy
everyone would achieve it
so this is one of the things that i i
try and rely on
when training's been getting hard i
ruptured my achilles a couple of years
ago that sucked i wouldn't advise it as
an injury generally yeah and it's like a
random
you know a lot of times people just do
it you know getting out of their car or
something i was playing cricket yeah the
most british way to snap into a very
british way to snap your achilles for
sure um
during that during the rehab for that
it's pretty just uncomfortable it's
endless calf raises right which not fun
and
the discomfort that you feel and the
pain the
fear of it re-rupturing which is the
number one thing you're doing it to have
happen the thing that i went back to in
my mind was this is why i'm here the
discomfort that i was feeling the um
effort the pain the sweat thankfully
this was during covid so it meant that
if i had to do a workout every single
morning for half an hour on just my
carbs like what else are you doing right
there's a pandemic going on um
this is why you're here was the reminder
it's like look this is the reason why
the re-rupture rate is
five to ten percent because people don't
want to do this thing
people don't want to do the thing
because it hurts because it takes half
an hour every single day for nearly 12
months it's a full 12 month recovery
that's why this is why you're here and i
think that you're right i think that the
selection is
people deep down know that picking up
heavy things physically
psychologically existentially culturally
is good for us and i think that that's
why it's attractive
i agree
another thing that i think is that
it's one of the reasons why people can
become a little bit triggered triggered
they can become a little bit
uncomfortable when they see somebody
else that's got a lot of discipline
because i think deep down they know that
if they had that thing that that would
fix a lot of the problems that they have
in their life is this a dynamic that you
that you've seen
i'm sure that's a a bummer for someone
to look at someone else that's working
really hard and
and achieving some positive things and
they know that they're not maybe working
as hard as they could be and they're not
really achieving what they want to
achieve
i'm sure that stings a little bit
another thing that jordan said recently
is that the problem with twitter is that
the price of being a prick has fallen to
zero i feel like you'd agree with that
as well
yeah
yeah i guess i'd agree with that if
you're gonna spend a bunch of time on
twitter you're gonna you're gonna run
into a bunch of people that don't like
you
and they're gonna say it and there's
nothing you can do about it so
and the ability for people's words and
the consequences of those words to
become detached as well is something
that's only pretty recent i mean i mean
i guess you could have
sent a mean telegram
100 years ago
yeah
i
i i would recommend that you don't let
random bots or
people on twitter bother you that much
that's that's my recommendation
i i would recommend you
you know the first time i kind of
experienced that it was when i was on
i was on rogan for the first time and
the youtube video came out
and i sat there with my oldest daughter
who was probably
maybe 14 or 15 at the time and
i sat there and read these
heinous comments about me and laughed
but i mean
it was kind of you know some were pretty
good it was kind of funny so
yeah i'm not i i'm not getting bothered
by
somebody that wants to talk smack about
me for whatever
on twitter and also there's there's
probably some truth to whatever they're
saying you know they say i'm a big
knuckle dragger yeah probably right
you know
they say i'm an idiot yeah there's
definitely some of that what else
do you swear much i don't think i've
ever heard you swear
i i don't swear a ton um
and look when i there's a there's a term
we have in america i don't know if you
have this in in england but swear like a
sailor meaning people in the navy swear
a lot
and certainly when i was
in the seal teams i
probably swore every seventh fifth to
seventh word that came out of my mouth
especially talking to a seal platoon
about something
but
no one i don't i don't swear a ton i
mean if you listen to my podcast all the
time you'll see that when there's an
appropriate time to swear
then i will but even it's interesting
you know if you square it all the time
it kind of loses its impact and so when
i do swear on the podcast people usually
say oh he's this is this is an important
thing business this is uh this is
obviously
a very very uh
powerful
emotion that he's feeling around because
he just said a swear word so yeah but i
don't swear a ton when i'm and even when
i was in the seal teams i'd come home at
night and when it's where i don't swear
in front of my wife and i wouldn't swear
in front of my kids
so
i would just turn it off and
that's that it's like when you hear sam
harris swear if you ever hear him yes
he's sprinkled very infrequently but
when it happens
okay yeah it's an attention-getter yeah
i have a friend daniel sloss uh comedian
uh and scottish so that combined is like
a multiplying force and um i actually
think that he probably uses more swear
words than actual words they're just
that salt bae guy it's kind of like that
but just throughout every single
sentence deprogramming i think is
important it's something that i've
really tried to work on you know just
being a working-class lad from the uk is
it's part and parcel of the language
perhaps is being in the seals
listening back
and especially hearing yourself speak a
lot which you've done over the last six
seven years or whatever
i don't know there's something about it
that i i just i would rather save it for
the times when i need it
yeah and
there is if you're doing something like
where people are going to listen to it
sort of detached from the moment that
you're living in then it's different as
well
so it doesn't have this it doesn't come
across the same and
you and i having a conversation over
lunch talking about whatever that that's
different and
you know those those words are a little
bit more fitting in those situations but
if you're watching the ufc
yeah if you're watching the ufc but
yeah
yeah i i i look i don't really if people
swear it's not it's not like a huge
concern of mine i don't really care that
much
but
maybe you could improve your vocabulary
a little bit and use it and not always
rely on the same five swear words
yeah
but some people use them well and
they're hilarious when they use them
daniel daniel uses his spectacularly
yeah i would say he's probably got a
black belt in in swearing
right on
i want to revisit your
good video
for the people that haven't seen it it's
a
two-minute long edit
that was released seven years ago on
your youtube channel and it's got like
nearly 10 million plays or something now
and in it you're encouraging people to
respond to setbacks and things that
don't go well
by saying good
by
leaning into the discomfort
by
seeing it as an opportunity
was there anything
you think that people misinterpreted
about that video or about
good generally as a concept
look if you take any idea and you take
it to an extreme
then that idea is going to become bad i
mean even the idea of extreme ownership
if you take it to an extreme where your
as you pointed out earlier you're
blaming yourself because
your daughter got a disease or you're
blaming yourself because your
husband is abusing you like there's a
point where you you think anything go
too far and
well you know
i mean there's there's some pretty good
memes about that on the internet yeah
there's some good memes about that on
the internet oh crashed my car my dog
died good yeah i needed a new car
anyways
so yeah take it to an extreme it can be
it can become pretty silly or funny
depending on how you take it but for the
most part you're gonna run into
challenges in life and if you curl up
into a ball
and complain about it
that's not gonna help you and if you say
okay cool good here's some adjustments i
can make to move forward that's gonna be
a better move than
then cowering
is there anything that you wish that
you'd added in
i
i don't know i mean i
said it during one of my podcasts and my
friend echo turned it into a video so so
that's it if i wanted to i probably
would have expanded on it or done
something else
um
i don't know do you tell me did i miss
something i don't think so i mean it's
pithy and obviously one of as you've
said there
it's extensive not exhaustive
as a solution
and this is
this is twitter in a nutshell that you
have to sacrifice um how explicit you're
being for brevity right for being
sufficiently succinct that people can
understand it you can get it in in one
minute 55 so that people can actually
watch it and won't click off or whatever
and
people will then use the
lack of detail
to
expand that out and say yeah
dog died in the car crash and good right
you you can see how that's easy to
criticize but i i think overall there's
this really great story actually it was
about zeno of city and the guy that
founded stoicism and uh often he was
criticized that he was very abrupt
when he would speak to people when he
was giving uh his because he was around
in a time of the sophists right and
sophistry was all about these big long
extravagant
um philosophical treaties and they would
use these super super long words and
stuff and
what he found was that people didn't
like the fact of how abrupt he was
didn't like that
and someone once criticized him for it
and he said uh yes i am thank you
if i could i would even shorten the
syllables as well
and i like the idea of someone that uses
brevity in an effective way
and uh
this sort of links in with something
i've been thinking about recently
which is to do
with the outcomes that we get in life so
all of the concerns that we have all of
the sleepless nights and the neuroses
and the overthinking and the confusion
and the uncertainty and the self-doubt
and all of that stuff all combined
together i think
probably net us about maybe five or ten
percent better outcomes in life it's my
belief that
most of the qualities that you have your
integrity your virtue your discipline
your hard work your growth mindedness
your humor your resilience all of that
are forces that are very very difficult
for you to slow down
and that once they've got started it's
incredibly hard for you to stop them and
what you're doing with all of the extra
concern that comes over the top of that
is just making your day-to-day
experience of it a lot more miserable
and i i've been thinking a lot about
how can you
how can you
i'm all fatty right the love of fate the
love of the destiny that i have is the
one that's going to come i understand
that i have control over it i understand
that i have agency that i have
sovereignty that i can impact my destiny
but also that all of the work and the
effort that i put in
previously is going to carry me through
and if i've been successful so far that
worrying about success going forward
whether or not it's going to
occur
just it doesn't seem super smart and
then relating that to
good
is that not only do you need to or can
you accept something and say that it is
good you can also have the sense of
resiliency that you know that you've got
through something that's worse than this
before how did you get on last time
did you face something that was
difficult
but you're still here by virtue of the
fact that you're listening to this
you're still here
and there's a part of that that makes me
it makes me think about
good is an active
philosophy right it's actively saying
something happens
i'm going to lean into it i'm going to
be
uh
forward motion right
and then the backup that you seem to
have behind that as well is
look at all of the things i've dealt
with before
look at all of the effectiveness that
i've come through with previously i
think that those two combined together
are
pretty powerful
i agree
speaking about
speaking about motivation and stuff as
well which is obviously kind of the
other side of of what you do you know
why i'm laughing right why because
you were telling the story about this
guy who gave really brief answers and
then you talked for six minutes and i
said i agree so it's just having fun
good man
you and zeno i've got a lot in common
maybe
do you think that people over complicate
motivation
yes
i find that
discussions about motivation a lot of
the time i mean you are the uh
soundtrack to a lot of motivation
compilation uh video that's right yeah
uh
motivation universe 40 minute get up and
get after it
jocko video um
so i i think that a lot of the
discussions about motivation can cause
people to believe
that there's some magical state that
they need to be in
before they do something
yeah and as i've said since day one it's
motivation is a feeling that comes and
goes and it doesn't matter whether it's
there or not discipline is infinitely
more important so no matter how you feel
get up and do what you're supposed to do
that's it and that's discipline it's not
motivation if you only did
what you were supposed to do when you
were motivated to do it that's leaving
it to chance
but if you're disciplined you go to what
you're supposed to do that's the way it
works
i went and listened to an episode you
did with sam harris
seven years ago now long time ago
he came up with this a really
interesting idea where he said that you
can't fake courage
that's one of the most interesting ways
to look at it he said that
courage or bravery i think is actually
what he was
talking about you it's an emotion that
you can't fake if you fake bravery when
you're terrified
that is bravery
and i kind of feel like motivation is
the same thing if you do the thing when
you're feeling unmotivated that is
motivation that's it so are you saying
that all of the jocko videos of
motivation they can just go off of
youtube well i i i say in a lot of those
videos and sometimes that's what it
takes for people to get motivated is to
realize that that motivation doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it's a
self-defeating video just shut up and go
do what you're supposed to do
yeah i mean the difference between the
person that spends all day weren't
wondering about whether they should go
to the gym or not
and the person that just goes to the gym
or not even if they both go
they net out at zero apart from the fact
that one person has spent the entire day
obsessing over it yeah and probably
wasting some brain power on it there's
this thing called the bro science called
the anxiety cost so you know opportunity
cost right that you because of doing one
thing you can't do another thing
anxiety cost to me is the wasted mental
effort that you go through obsessing
over something when you could fix it
quite easily
by just doing it
it's one of the most compelling reasons
for doing a morning training workout for
me if you go to train every day ev every
morning when you wake up your daily
to-do list resets right you get out of
bed and then your to-do list of
meditate and walk the dog and answer
emails and do all that
the sooner that you can front load that
stuff
the rest of the day is just
yeah discipline equals freedom
that's it
i mean if you have the discipline to get
up and get the things done
well i i've i usually i often tell a
similar story this is the same thing
that you just said which is you know the
weekend where
you really only had two things to do for
the weekend whatever it was you had to
write this thing
and you had to answer this other thing
and on friday you're like i'll do it
tomorrow and on saturday like i'll do it
and it's basically hanging over your
head the whole weekend whereas if you're
just done friday afternoon the whole
weekend would have been a lot better
so just do the thing
i agree with you just do it just do this
just do the thing man what does courage
mean to you is that a good definition
from sam do you think doing doing the
thing in spite of the way that you feel
yeah i think that's i think that's solid
i i i somebody asked me a question the
other day does courage have to involve
risk and i thought about it a little bit
i haven't thought i don't sit around and
think about a lot of stuff
which might be obvious i guess but
yeah i think if you're gonna if you're
gonna get credit for courage then there
has to be some level of risk whether
it's you know
capital risk and doing something in
business or
physical risk if you're doing something
to
run into a fire to save somebody yeah so
i think
i think courage has to have some kind of
risk involved and then yes i agree with
sam harris when he pointed out that if
you're
acting
if you're doing the thing then that's
courage no matter how you feel inside
your your little brain
are you sure that you don't spend that
much time
sat around thinking of stuff because i
know that you you do a ton of prep for
each of your podcast episodes and as
you're reading through a book i mean
the insights that you pull out of that
that you drag across between i think you
might be doing yourself a bit of a
disservice there
well
yes when i'm reading a book i'm
certainly
applying the context of my life and my
experiences and what i know and
what i think i know to that so i guess
but but that's different than sitting
around and thinking oh you mean like the
the sort of the
stroking i don't do a lot of that maybe
i should do more i probably need to i'd
be interested to see that i could see
you sat in a smoking jacket somewhere
cigar
yeah i mean you you know i i i think
when i run i think when i'm doing jiu
jitsu i surfing yeah i think when i'm
surfing and those are just
that's that's a great kind of empty mind
and and there's times where i'm running
and i have to stop and write something
down you know i'll pull out my because
i'll be listening to some music or
something i'll stop and take a note
in in my iphone about something that i
just thought of
so it happens
courage is very hard to find when life
gets comfortable
for people
how can they stop their bravery from
eroding when times are easy
i guess i guess
what we already talked about
do something that's hard and do it every
day that's what's one of the nice things
about jiu jitsu you're going to get
choked you're going to be uncomfortable
you're going to get smashed you're going
to have to tap out your ego is going to
get abused
your
go do that
go do that
go for a run lift just do hard stuff
and that's a good way to
keep that
i guess fresh you think that maps across
onto other areas of life as well
it certainly seems like it does
but there's no guarantee on any of this
stuff really
there's no guarantee and it depends on
what you know what kind of courage
you're talking about are we talking
about courage where
you're gonna die or you could possibly
die or you you know is that what we're
calling courage because there's people
that have come from every walk of life
that have stepped up in that situation
and there's people that have come from
every walk of life and have failed in
that situation so
if you're talking life or death
yeah i mean i think you actually have to
get someone that is sort of good with
dying and they're okay with it and then
they're gonna have a lot easier time
pushing into that
fold
if it shows up
have you seen those detroit self defense
videos
uh yeah i i think
oh i know i have i'm trying to think how
i saw him but yeah cause a lot of
jiu-jitsu people will will repost those
things yeah
what
what do you think that people
misunderstand when it comes to life and
death
fights street fights
what do you think most normal people who
haven't been in one
misbelief
i don't know what that has to do with
those detroit videos those detroit
videos are definitely uh
it's a pantomime yeah so i i guess
so
i guess what to answer your question
what do most people not understand about
a street fight
they're probably not used to just the
level of violence that's going to occur
they're not there
maybe this is maybe this is what you're
getting at with the detroit uh
self-defense videos or whatever they are
the choreographed maneuvers that you
that work when you and i are going
through them and sort of dancing
those aren't going to work in real life
and
so if you think that you're going to be
able to drop someone with one punch or
you think all those things that that
that
are sort of the old traditional martial
arts doing kata and i you know i do this
to you and it causes this reaction then
my next move is over here yeah this
stuff doesn't really work in a street
fight just
yeah
the groin kick and the
palm of the hand to the nose to run away
from the the female to run away from the
attacker and stuff like that yep it's
not going to work well
and it's not very reliable
if you want to learn how to fight you
got to learn how to fight
you know you got to do jiu jitsu muay
thai wrestling boxing that's what you
need to do if you want to learn how to
fight
have you been to go and see what tim
kennedy's doing i at his place with his
self-defense courses i have not been to
one of his courses it's called sheepdog
response but i've seen what he's doing
and
of course you know tim's tim's a not
only is he well versed in martial arts
clearly he's also well versed in weapons
and he's also well versed in violence
and so i know
what he's teaching is legit stuff i'm
pretty sure they're using live handheld
tasers as well during that to just show
people precisely how difficult it is to
whatever do the the face palm and the
eye gouge and the fish hook and
run away and uh
i think he runs i think he must be
monthly he does a special one for
not military personnel for um
the police
and um
even them the amount of training i think
i mean we've seen this recently right
that the training seems to be
insufficient yeah the training for
police officers is totally insufficient
and it's it's horrible because it's a
very difficult job that you should be
training
i i've been saying for the last several
years that police officers should train
20 of the time
20 of the time that they work they
should be training and
right now it's not even it's probably
not even a measurable percentage of time
that they're working i mean it's
probably in the fractions of a percent
that they're training they get horrible
training
and they're in really dynamic situations
and in doing an incredibly hard job
you don't know how to do that stuff you
know you talk about the misconceptions
of the street fight is the person that
thinks well you know when i if someone
messes with me i'm just going to get
wild and they think that's going to work
and that's not going to work especially
against someone that's trained
so
if you think that you're going to have
some magical powers because you're angry
or because your adrenaline's going
that's not that's not true and it's
going to it's going to cost you in a big
way especially if you come up against
somebody like tim kennedy who's
genuinely trained oh for sure yeah and
you know this day and age
well i mean i live in san diego
california
a lot of people train a lot of people
train i wouldn't say it's the majority
of people trained but there are a lot if
you get in a fight in san diego there's
a decent chance you're fighting against
someone that knows how to fight
and
look there's jujitsu on every street in
san diego jiu jitsu academies
so
yeah if you just think you're going to
be a tough guy
it's
it's going to be rough it's going to be
a rough tour
i saw a video the other day that you may
have seen as well of tim talking about
changes he was making to his everyday
carry
you see this uh i don't say i don't
think so he was changing the uh weapon
that he was using the pistol um because
recently some of the active shooters
have been using body armor
so he's now gone to a relatively small
caliber but uh
armor-piercing round
are you
concerned about this
increasing sophistication that seems to
be coming from people that are shooters
yeah there's a little there's an
escalation there right but
that's uh
the the military went through this with
the people we were fighting they start
wearing body armor cool roger that you
want to wear body armor we'll we'll get
arm repairing rounds
you know the the it
it's just a natural escalation of things
unfortunately but
it's the way it is it's kind of like the
predator prey dynamic right of evolution
yeah
yeah
the the enemy's gonna make adjustments
and we're gonna have to adjust back
what are your principles for an everyday
are you allowed can you have an everyday
carry in in uh san diego yes right what
are your principles that you follow for
for that
the the same as a normal person that
wants to protect themselves
well we had this recent fourth of july
shooting right and then before that we
had eval day and then before that we had
buffalo have you got any idea if this is
the sort of thing that can be
stopped or can be restricted in some way
yeah i did i did some podcasts on these
things and
some of the the biggest
or i would say one of the most startling
things and
about as you watch the evolution of this
so in
in 1955
in america
there was
340
inpatient beds
for people with mental health issues
per 100 000 people so for every 100 000
people in america there was 340
inpatient beds
for those people from people with mental
health problems
in 2007 it was
17 beds per hundred thousand
so
their the the mental health
capacity
for treatment in america has gone down
in what 95
and the re and there are some legitimate
reasons why this happened and a lot of
it had to do with the fact that people
were getting put in these institutions
and they there were some horrible
abuses that were going on in some of
these mental institutions people being
committed that didn't want to be in
there people that were abused once they
were in there people that could never
get out of there and there was a
backlash against that and it all of a
sudden became in the 70s hey this this
mental health these mental health
facilities are evil they're bad there's
abuse going on we need to shut them down
and they shut down a lot of them and so
in doing that it certainly appears to me
that they threw the baby out with the
bathwater and now we've got
i mean you think san diego there's two
or three million people here
there's a lot of people that need help
that need help
mental health help and there's just not
a great place to get it
you know i talk police officers a lot
police officers come upon people all the
time that they don't need to get put in
jail they need to get put in some kind
of a mental health facility but they
don't exist
and so they go into jail for a little
while they they come back out
and
it's a problem
so so if you take just the numbers of
the beds right
what has that done to all the other
aspects of mental health like all what
about the outpatient people how many
doctors used to be ready to help
somebody that was feeling depressed or
was feeling angry there probably were a
lot more doctors back then that had the
capability of treating those things so
we've
we've
really shut down our capacity to help
people from a mental health perspective
and then on top of that we've added all
these things into society that
create
more mental health problems i.e drugs
alcohol
social media
uh the the fact that someone can stay in
their house all the time but then we put
covet on people where they had to stay
in their house all the time they're
getting stuck in echo chambers there's
all these things that add to mental
health problems and we've we've really
done away with a lot of the treatment
that we had before
so
hopefully in in the coming months and
years we can start to get back to a
place
where we start to build up our
capacity for
treating help people that have mental
health issues because these these
shooters in these scenarios they clearly
are
they have mental health problems it's a
trend as well that's dominated by young
men it seems and that that seems
especially sad because these are men
that could be out
working a job or starting a business or
being in the armed forces contributing
to something and instead they're off on
a
rampage somewhere it's horrible to see
one of the differences we were talking
before we started about the differences
between the us and the uk i've spent a
lot of time late nights in city centers
working night clubs
and um
i've spent a lot of time around homeless
people at two in the morning the only
people that are out are club promoters
and and homeless people and
party goers
and uh the difference
between homeless people in the uk
and homeless people in the us
is
more stark than the difference between
the cultures
by distance
they are
significantly more
antsy uh
evidently um in discomfort and and
talking to themselves shuffling along
uh
rocking backward and forward
much more forthcoming significantly more
forthcoming significantly more
aggressive even though i've never had
anything super bad happen
uh
downtown san diego downtown denver
downtown austin
i haven't spent a ton of time in america
but i mean
there are a lot of them and
the safety net that we have in the uk to
sweep up people who fall through the
cracks like that
is
it it seems to work right you know
someone someone ends up in a really bad
way mentally
away you go will pop you into a ward
you'll be looked after we'll be given
the medication that you need there's no
insurance that restricts that but as you
said earlier on it's like a vicious
cycle of the people who are the ones
that are the most vulnerable are the
ones that maybe get sent to jail perhaps
to get hooked on drugs the drugs make
their mental health conditions worse
which means that they can
they've further ingrained themselves
into a life of either crime or
homelessness which takes them further
away from a job in a balanced life and
yeah i mean it kind of doesn't surprise
me but it's it's pretty sad to see yeah
i'd be interested to know the numbers of
of
inpatient beds per 100 000 in the uk
because if you think about the homeless
people that you've seen in san diego
and there's two million people here
right there's a lot of those people that
probably would be swept up and put into
a place where they're getting the right
mental health treatment that they need
and mental health treatment is not an
easy thing to do it can take an extended
period of time to get someone sorted to
a point where they're able to be go out
and contribute to society so yeah i'd be
interested to know those numbers and
even from what you're saying right now
my guess is
england's probably doing a better job of
getting people the help that they need
how long have you been married now
i think
25
years and you met your wife in bahrain
right yep you remember the story about
the first thing that you said to her yes
would you tell that
uh yeah so
i was on a on a
deployment in the navy i was on a ship
while we were on a ship this is back
before internet on ships and
we
to occupy our time when you're a seal on
a ship there's nothing to do you don't
have a job so you just sleep eat and
lift is our joke
and you can only sleep eat and lift so
long and then we we had a certain
selection of movies
on videotapes and so one of the movies
that we had was aceventure a pet
detective with jim carrey and so we did
a lot of imitating ace venture a pet
detective
and
when i so we eventually went to bahrain
my
the other squad there's two squads in
the seal platoon the other squad had
actually gone to bahrain before us
squad two went to bahrain for a few days
they were ahead of us
and we didn't know anything about
bahrain we didn't know what was going on
there because there's again there's no
internet you just know some going to
some random place in the desert
and squad one had work to do so we
stayed on the boat for a couple extra
days
and then when we finally flew to bahrain
squad two was waiting for us and they
were they were saying hey this place is
like there's
good times to be had there's bars and
girls and the whole nine yards
and so they had like they were staged
and ready to take us out
and
yeah we went to a bar and i know a big
giant packed kind of club slash bar and
and i saw a
tall beautiful blonde woman
and actually actually one of my friends
in squad two
had said to me oh there's these two
girls you're gonna be
he's like i know you're gonna talk to
him and he was kind of a shire guy and i
said i'm sure it would work out with you
man you're you'll do fine
and
sure enough i walked in this bar saw my
saw my future wife and i just i walked
up to her and i said in like a jim
carrey tone
i said uh should i just call you
aphrodite's goddess of love
and she looked at me like i was an idiot
which was accurate and then you know i
bought her a drink and the rest as they
say is history how did you save that i i
want to know how you turned that opening
line around
you know it was i did it in a ridiculous
enough way that she could
probably tell i wasn't taking myself too
seriously i mean it
it wasn't serious right so if you're not
being serious she laughed and we were
good i didn't i didn't say it i didn't
say should i just call you aphrodite
goddess of love no if i would have said
that i
probably wouldn't have ended up with her
but i was having fun what have you
learned since being married to a brit
is there anything that uh you think has
been a unique insight
you know britain england the uk long
allies with america even though i guess
originally it didn't start off that way
clearly look the fourth of july was a
very difficult day for me yeah it was a
very difficult day
happy treason day to all of the
ungrateful colonialists
uh no i i i love the historical aspects
of england uh you know the the
the the military that i've worked with
the brits that i've worked with
kind of to me represent what i think of
when i want when i think of england and
when i
the way i the way i kind of hold england
and the uk
in an elevated way in my mind
the the british military that i've
worked with have maintained that
standard completely professional stiff
upper lip
squared away
ready to work
and just just just the really just
professional and that's the way i always
think of england
i'm interested here in the disciplining
process
of getting married and becoming a father
because you were someone who had already
worked hard on
being disciplined but this feels like a
very different
type of discipline to the discipline
to
put up with a baby that won't stop
crying
it's the
discipline
to be able to comfort somebody while
you're away from them
that to me
feels like a different sort of frequency
of of discipline and i'm interested in
[Music]
what you found as a challenge and what
you found as um
whether your military career had uh
prepared you for marriage and fatherhood
effectively
well first of all
uh
insane amount of credit goes to my wife
who
is
just she well one of the things i've
tried to explain to people about her is
that she was emotionally independent
meaning
she
didn't need me to
to
bolster her up and
she handled everything she handled
everything on the home front
literally everything
and i would just go and go do my job and
she never
complained about that
she never
made any comments about it
it was she knew kind of the priority for
me was
my job
and that later on in life and and that
strategically
in our lives
the the priority was the family but she
also knew that while i was in the seal
teams that was my number one priority
she knew that and i told her that and
she said yeah i know i get it
do you take care of your team you take
care of your platoon you take care of
your task unit
and i got this i got these kids and this
house and all that other stuff
and she never complained she never
she just she just did it and so the the
majority the vast majority of credit
goes to my wife for being an awesome
human being an awesome uh mom to our
kids
and
i was i would love to give you some kind
of
this is what you need to look for
and that's probably the best i could do
but i can't say that i looked for it i
got very very lucky i i got very lucky
that my wife was
was
look you can judge her looks and i
obviously she was and is a beautiful
woman
but the luck part was
she was
like i said emotionally independent she
was
strong to be able to handle
just
just mayhem mayhem on a pretty regular
basis
you know not you know from from
having a bunch of kids
to i'm gone on deployment
and my wife is
going to visit my wounded guys in the
hospital or going to my guy's funerals
that's what she was doing so
[Music]
you know team effort for sure but she's
the mvp and i'm just sort of
you know the the the bench the bench
warmer over here
the
the now all that being said
the
the
you know from the military
look taking ownership of things which
which i already talked about a little
bit but
there's nothing really that goes on in
my family that i don't
that that i would say no to my wife no
that's your fault because i can just
about guarantee that everything is my
fault
when when there's something that's not
right when there's
something going wrong
it's something that i it's a mistake
that i made i did something wrong
de-escalation right
because my wife while borderline saint
there you know she's a human being
a lot of my friends would argue that
she's just a saint but she is a human
being
and you know she might get mad about
something she might get frustrated with
me about something and
being able to de-escalate those
situations
and
not
not escalate them is very very
beneficial
and one of the best ways to do that is
by taking ownership when something goes
wrong
so i would say the de-escalation part
taking ownership is definitely
beneficial
if you're blaming your your wife you're
probably
that's not going to work out great
and and just the idea of
you know trying to win trying to win an
argument i mean first of all honestly i
don't really are i
i don't really argue with my wife i
probably have been in
less than a handful less than
three or four arguments in my life with
my wife
and i can't even i can't even really
think of anything right now i just don't
want to you know
try and try and make myself out or make
our relationship out to be something
that's not but we don't really argue
very often and
so i can't even really say that
hey
don't try and win an argument with your
wife because i'm not really having an
argument with my wife
um
i guess my i guess my synopsis of this
is pay attention to who you're going to
get married to
and
try and pick someone that is
emotionally
independent
that has their own
has their own
that can handle life by themselves and
that that can be that can make some
people feel insecure right like i want
someone that's relying on me all the
time and i want them to feel like they
need me
and that might be a trap for you if
that's what you set yourself up with so
that's what i do find someone that's
emotionally independent find someone
that you get along well with find
someone that's
that's
um
calm
you know someone that's not you know
that's not going to get get bent out of
shape about little things
and if they do a little de-escalation
can kind of get the problem solved
and then just uh have fun you know my
wife and i have fun
and i think that's important
it's very interesting to think about the
fact that some people rely on a partner
who is
overly vulnerable
or
overly anxiously attached
as a way to bolster their own sense of
reassurance in a relationship i've seen
this quite a lot yeah that's probably
not going to be a great move
and look you
a person i don't know everyone all i can
do is talk for myself
and
i would recommend you find someone
that's more you're equal
someone that you can engage with someone
that's someone that you're part of a
team with rather than someone that
you're sort of domineering over i
learned this the other day that there's
only one sentence in the bible
about
how you should choose a partner
and it says that you should choose
someone that you could go to war with
i like it
that works
that's legit
it's a team effort a relationship right
and
would you purposefully choose a
particularly vulnerable teammate because
you're always going to be
the person that's out in front
probably not yeah
yeah
now to push back a little bit about that
look you you there's guys i would be
number one on my list
to go to war with
that probably are not going to be the
best spouses in them you wouldn't get in
a relationship with them
they're they're going to be they're
going to be tough for for a female to be
married too
because they're they're wild right
they're wild animals and they're the
exact type of person that you would want
to go to war with and that i've gone to
war with and a lot of times they're
they're not going to be great
as as husbands fair point yes yeah
people as well i've been thinking
recently i spoke to andre huberman last
week and he was explaining to me about
the similarities between
the grief process and the breaking up
process apparently neurologically it's
incredibly similar it's a
distance
in
time and space and something else i
think and he was talking about how when
you go through a breakup it is the same
[Music]
networks that are activated as through
grief
and as somebody that has been to
probably far more military funerals than
we can remember or would have liked to
how does that inform
your advice for people letting go of
people that they lose in their life
whether that be through a breakup or or
through them passing
i talked about this on my podcast one
time and
speaking of jocko videos that are out
there and people have made videos of
this
yes i have
definitely lost
too many of my friends and it took me a
little while to start getting pattern
recognition on what what happens and
it's a very clear pattern and once i
kind of put that out there i've now
heard from many many scores of people
that yup that's what it feels like
and i think if you know what it's going
to feel like just like anything else if
you know what to expect then it's easier
to contend with so
it's like a storm that is hitting you
you know you lose someone someone that
you know dies you are going to get put
into a storm
and what's scary about it is it's it's
an emotional storm and you have no
control over it so you're gonna break
down start crying you're gonna
remember
bad things good things you're not gonna
be in control of your emotions which is
very difficult for adults because we're
used to having some level of control
over our emotions so for a period of
time you're gonna get hit with waves of
emotion that you have no control over
and they're gonna knock you off your
feet and you're not gonna be able to
finish a sentence you're gonna
it's it it's very very difficult
but over time
that storm is going to fade a little bit
and those those waves are going to get
weaker
and and those waves still may come so i
don't know if you've lost anyone that's
close to you no which is one of the
reasons that i'm i'm an only child two
parents
like dogs dogs is it
so i have a particular um
interest right
so there's gonna be times where it's
been a month since your friend died and
you're gonna be sitting there and you're
gonna hear a song or you're gonna smell
a burger that you you you once had with
this individual and you're gonna get
overcome with those waves of emotion
again and you might start crying right
there you might have this massive wave
of emotion hit you
and it'll and then it'll subside
and over time the waves will become
weaker and they'll become less frequent
and and here's where people also get
into trouble they think that that means
that they didn't care about that person
and that's not true at all it's just
that your mind is processing it and it's
okay
so
that's what happens you start off with
this huge uncontrollable emotional storm
that storm will pass that's number one
just know that that storm is normal
and it's gonna pass
and then
it's gonna still hit you but over time
those waves
of sadness and sorrow are gonna get
weaker and they're gonna get less
frequent and that's okay that's a good
thing
and look i haven't broken up with a with
a girl in a long time
but
i you know when when people ask me about
breaking up with girls is you know i've
what you have to do when it's not
working with a girl is
wish them luck
to give them the best of luck wish them
luck
walk away and don't look back
and you're still going to get those
emotions those things are still going to
hit you but walk away and don't look
back and there's two reasons for that
number one
if there's any chance
that it's going to work out the best
possible way for you to get it to work
out is by walking away by wishing them
look walk away and don't look back
that's the best way how so because if
there is something there
then
she will let you know eventually
and if there's nothing there you're
gonna know that too because you never
hear from her again that's fine
the protocol for getting her back
is to walk away and don't look back
that's the protocol is to move on
the protocol if she doesn't want you
back is to walk away and don't look back
so i look and i know it's hard
but
you'll you'll get some of those waves
but those waves will become less
frequent and they'll become less
powerful and eventually you can move on
and then you know the last thing i'll
say about this is in both these
scenarios is remember but don't dwell
so you got you look you remember your
friends you honor your friends you
remember what they gave you what they
taught you what you learned from them
what was great about them what you miss
about them you remember all those things
but you don't dwell in the past and and
dwell on those thoughts and dwell on the
loss all the time because that's not
healthy either and it's not not going to
help you it's not what your friend would
want you to do anyways
i like the insight around when you
are going through grief
and then you stop
the sense of guilt that comes through
because you feel
now somehow that you're
doing a disservice to their memory like
you didn't really care
or something like that yeah
it helps to
you know it helps to write about
what i've told people to do is write
that personal letter
and tell them
what you loved about them what you're
going to miss about them how you felt
about them what you regret you write all
that stuff in a letter put an envelope
bring it to their grade and put it there
and and that will help you process as
well i mean i've
unfortunately or fortunately i've i've
given a bunch of eulogies for friends
that i've lost and
in the beginning i didn't really
recognize that that's a way of healing
but
certainly writing down your emotions
your feelings what you're gonna miss
what you loved about them is very
therapeutic and it's very good and so
that's another thing i recommend is you
write that stuff down and and you
you bring it to him that's another
petersonism from his rules for life he
says if memories still make you cry
write them down
yeah
that's a you know i talk a lot about
being able to detach from your emotions
and it's very important well when you
write something down you are
literally detaching from those thoughts
because they're going out on a piece of
paper that then you can see
so it's a very important thing to do to
write down
if there's emotions that you have to
deal with write down and i'd just like
to give someone some kind of an
objective
so instead of just saying write down the
emotions no here's write that person
tell them and that will kind of be like
a writing prompt
to get you to write the right things
about that situation
i'm pretty interested in your impact on
kids so i had a comment
uh from a father saying how much he
couldn't wait for this episode because
his son's read all of your books and
we're timing my nine-year-olds mile run
times every week because of jocko so if
if nothing else there is a nine-year-old
out there with his dad stood at the
stopwatch as he sprints around a park on
a saturday morning or something at the
moment
what what business does a seal have
writing kids books
well
i don't know necessarily if any seal has
any business doing anything i know that
i have four kids and that i wanted to
when i was raising my kids there was
there wasn't really any books that
carried the message
of the values that i wanted my kids to
have
and so i just wrote my own and
there you go
pretty straightforward is that similar
to you uh do you think entering into the
is it a reflection there from the seals
the fact that there wasn't a guidebook
or a handbook uh
for operations when you first came in
and you've almost
had this twice you've had this in uh
both your career and in fatherhood as
well yeah like there is there are some
weaknesses to not having doctrine and
there's also some strength when you do
have doctrine
and you know you know that boiled down
to
l i was very lucky that i joined the
military because when i joined the
military
it
it was
i i had a structure a pathway to
execute on
and that's very very beneficial
for a young idiot kid that's filled with
energy and rebellion and aggression
that's that's awesome here take all that
energy and aggression and rebellion and
and focus in this direction it's going
to be beneficial and you'll actually get
rewarded for it you'll get promoted for
it that's amazing
and kids
didn't really have any kind of a code
where hey these are some general rules
that will that you will benefit from in
life
and so there you go that's the warrior
kid
what about kids or the parents of kids
that are being bullied in school this to
me seems like a very
unique challenge
generally for people to come up against
because a lot of the time
you're able to have an impact on a
situation you're able to do something
that moves it forward but
you know you can go and have a
conversation with the head teacher or
whatever but that doesn't necessarily
fix culturally sort of what's going on
within the school there's only so much
that teachers can do in terms of
oversight
you can't go into the school and
punch the other kid in the face but
that's also not the solution as much as
you might want to do that well it's not
going to help your kid any either
right
you you have to train your kid to be
able to contend with the world not tell
your kid that you're always going to be
there to back them up and beat up anyone
that gets in their way like that's not
going to help your kid become a better
human
so
no what you want to do is teach your kid
what you want to do to actually teach
your kid how to fight you want your kid
to train jiu jitsu you want your kid to
train boxing you want your kid to be
an actual force to be reckoned with and
and what's crazy about this is you know
as you mentioned earlier
if there's a bigger a much bigger person
than you
they can still beat you up you know and
that's the thing with kids you know if
you're 10 years old you can be a really
well well-trained 10 year old but a 14
year old is probably going to get the
better of you and maybe 15 year old but
there's still going to be situations
that it's going to be you're going to
lose a fight
that being said
the risk for the bully
goes
exponentially higher
when he knows that he's got someone on
his hands that can actually actually
knows how to fight
and so the probability of bullying
taking place goes
way down way down and
even if that bully wins the fight he's
not going to look good it's going to be
a problem he he's going to he's going to
get a
a vic a worthless victory
because he's going to beat up he's going
to barely
get the better of someone that's a lot
smaller than than the bully himself so
and all this stuff
all this stuff i guess we could talk to
andrew huberman
but this is stuff you recognize there's
a there's a primal recognition
of someone that knows how to fight
and someone that doesn't
and
this is this is
kids can recognize this they recognize
oh
i'm getting in this kid's face and he
doesn't seem to be bothered by this
and he's got a little bit of a smile on
his face
i might not want to push this any
further and and that's a real thing so
jiu-jitsu boxing wrestling muay thai
will elevate that
primordial confidence
in a young man or a young boy or young
girl that is going to prevent so much
bullying from happening that it's
incredible
so
look can you still get beat up yes you
absolutely can are you probably going to
do okay yes you most likely are is your
now what's what's lame
is you know if you go back
pre-ufc
there would be
martial arts instruction that would hey
we're going to help your kid with their
confidence
and they would kids would get more
confident but it wasn't based on reality
you know going back to the detroit you
know your friend at the detroit defense
tactical or whatever you're calling my
friend going back to that guy
he's teaching things that might help
someone's confidence but they're not
going to help in real life yes so is
that potentially even more dangerous oh
it's it's infinitely more dangerous
because a kid that knows jiu jitsu a 10
year old kid that knows jujitsu and and
there's a 14 year old kid that kid knows
hey even though i know jiu-jitsu it's
gonna be a problem this kid's a lot
bigger than me he's probably stronger
than me and this is gonna be a problem i
need to figure out a way to de-escalate
this as opposed to getting told hey all
you have to do is this strike and that
that strike and then you'll win a fight
no that's actually not true
so yes that is more harmful to have
somebody with fake confidence
that that's a real problem but
in training
and in becoming stronger and being able
to do pull-ups and being able to run you
know for the young kid that's running
that kid's got some good cardio if he's
time in his mile runs right all those
things are gonna help
make a more capable human who is a lot
less likely by the way he's more
confident guess what else he has when
he's more confident he's got more
friends
his friends are now looking at this
bully going hey man you don't want to
mess with our friend and now we have a
situation where it's probably going to
get de-escalated just because
of of school yard politics and primal
politics that that play out between any
group of human beings
i'll never forget when i was in
secondary school one of my friends carl
his grandad was a
judo
teacher and had been for a very very
long time and carl had done it since he
could walk as soon as he walked he was
he was doing judo and he's now
14 15. there's a one of those kids in
school that must have hit puberty at
nine or something and this guy's huge
and he was one of the the big bullies in
school and i'll never forget that he
squared up to him and carl was grinning
in his face
smiling in his face just couldn't wait
for something to happen and i think that
that kind of highlights
one of the main differences getting in a
fight is probably not that bad as a kid
in fact it could be a useful formative
experience to
make you um
to educate you in the future about what
it feels like to be in a physical
altercation with people
the thing that's concerning is the fear
around the fight right it's the anxiety
and the worries about the bullying so in
a way
yes the skills you need to have the
skills that actually back up you don't
want to have a reality which is detached
from what you predict is going to happen
but one of the most important things
is to just feel comfortable
in a situation that is going to become
dynamic 100
uh you know i i tell this when i start
talking to women about self-defense
if you have never had someone grab hold
of you
the mental
hurdle you have to get over just to be
able to respond in an adequate way
is immense that mental hurdle is immense
if you do jiu jitsu someone's grabbing a
hold of you 27 times a day
on the mat they're grabbing your neck
they're grabbing your arm you're totally
used to this to this close proximity
combat that you're entering into
so
yes
a huge benefit of training to fight is
that you don't have any mental hurdle to
get over your friend that trained judo
his whole life he was just ready to rock
and roll at that point there's no fear
whatsoever this is what he does every
single day
that's
again
a great reason to get out there and
train it's kind of like a superpower uh
yes it's 100 jiu jitsu is 100 a
superpower there's no doubt about it i
mean it's 100
you know what that's
one of my kids asked me when it was my
son he asked me when he was a little kid
the movie the incredibles came out
and he said hey dad is there really such
a thing as superpower and i said
hmm
yes there is it's a little thing that
you do every day it's called jiu jitsu
and and eventually he realized that oh
i i can actually
fight anybody and it's going to be fine
and that's a very beneficial thing to
have
because
there's always
i guess i'm a little bit biased because
of the way kind of the
how i grew up there's always violence
there's always some sort of
inferred level of violence i mean a seal
platoon there's a pecking order you know
and it has to do with with fighting
and and that's the same with any group
of of
of knuckle dragger neanderthal men that
are in a group there's always a guy
that's that yeah that guy's kind of he's
the one that can kind of beat everyone
up
that's the way it is so i'm sorry that
it's that way i'm sorry it's not a
cerebral contest but
there's only two forms of communication
one of them is words and the other one
is violence and when the first one fails
that's when the second one comes about
and i i absolutely think dude i've stood
on the front door of a thousand club
nights right i've met about a million
people stood on the front door of
nightclubs i have seen
literally hundreds of fights occur when
people have had a bit to drink
and i spoke to a
an anthropologist um and he was drawing
parallels between the ways
that
particularly guys um when they first
start to fight especially if their
inhibitions are lowered a little bit uh
and he was drawing a parallels between
that and the way that other animals
fight as well so he said one of the
first things that you'll see men do is
that they'll start to circle each other
he said what did dear do you know
when they've got the they've got their
antlers and they'll circle what they're
doing they're kind of they're sizing
each other up and they'll circle and
they'll circle and they'll circle and
then they'll come in and they'll push
first maybe and what's that doing oh
it's getting kind of a feel for what's
going on it's getting a sense of just
how big is it do i really really want to
go do i want to go do it right i'll give
it a and then maybe come back and do it
again and then circle a little bit more
and circle a little bit more i thought
it was so fascinating do i really want
to go do they really want to go too like
maybe i can just get away with a push
and they'll realize that yeah there's
some definite comparisons there there's
i'm sorry to inform everybody but we're
animals
and that stuff some of us
yeah some of us more than others
i
just thought that were you talking about
women doing brazilian jiu jitsu
is there some is there a particularly
unique challenge i mean women are
very hardwired to avoid being
grabbed and and
laid on by a
man that's much larger than them even if
it is in a controlled situation right
even if it isn't in a class or whatever
there's some particularly unique
challenges that the girls have when they
begin to do brazilian jiu jitsu or have
you have you found that there are
hurdles that girls have to get over just
generally is there something like innate
in their programming that kind of causes
them to
to react in a in a different way
yeah
um
i would say it's not normal for a girl
or a woman to want some dude all up on
them
and that's what jiu jitsu is you are all
up on each other and
you know it's
it's
a very for lack of a better word it's
very intimate con contact that you're
having with another human being so
there's
it is a hurdle it's absolutely a hurdle
for
for women and girls to get over and once
i get over it it's like okay cool and
then
it's much better to get over it on the
mats in a jujitsu academy than it is to
have to contend with that psychological
hurdle when you're
in a problematic scenario and you're
being attacked that is not the time to
try and figure out
what matters and what doesn't matter and
what this feels like and what that feels
like and
yeah you want to train and you want to
overcome that hurdle in a nice safe
environment
thinking about the
bullying topic
i was considering about what that causes
in later life so i had a
bit of a tough sort of school
upbringing with bullying and stuff like
that
and i was thinking about it
reflecting on it a lot and i realized
that a lot of the things
that that created downstream in later
life are the things that i most value in
myself
and this has been a very difficult thing
for me to to kind of pass to just work
out like
i'm gonna invite
do i need to
thank
the bullies in a way have they created
some of the
things in myself that i most value so
for instance
um
moved out to america to come and do the
podcast
that has only been afforded to me really
because i don't care about being
solitary i don't care about being on my
own i don't care about taking risks
because
for a very long time i was in any case
on my own and
everything was a risk going to school
was a risk or
going out for lunch was a risk or
whatever and then
thinking about how
thinking about how i uh noticed certain
things
right i went to a party not long ago and
was obsessed about the fact for about
the first five minutes obsessed about uh
half of the people had taken their shoes
and socks off but half of the people had
only taken their shoes off and left
their socks on but the reason that i was
paying so much attention is because in
school i would obsess over um the way
that certain kids had their hair cut or
the way that they would carry their bag
or the way that they would do their tie
because i was sure that that was the
reason that they had friends and i
didn't i was trying to deconstruct in
other people
socially what was going on with them
that meant that they and obviously i
didn't realize it's that they were
sociable probably and were communicating
well and whatever you know a classic
only child with like
sprinkling of autism or whatever so like
um but i really value that i value the
fact
i i paid that much attention
and it got me thinking more and more
about
a lot of the things that we really value
in ourselves as adults
are the light side of something that we
probably are a little bit embarrassed
about
and i was wondering whether
first off whether you see that dynamic
in yourself whether there are there are
things that you most value that that
have um costs that you need to pay
and then also whether
perfect childhoods create weak adults
so going back to the conversation i had
with sam harris
um he kind of called me out
on the fact that i had said
something along the lines is of combat
was sort of when i most felt alive and
i wouldn't trade it for anything
and i also would say
the worst days of my life were in war
losing my friends and war is horrible
and
the way i responded to it and i asked
him if he had anyone
had ever known anyone that had cancer
and had come out the other side and he
said yes and i said
oftentimes those people say
i wouldn't wish it on anybody but i'm
glad it happened to me because it gave
me such a better perspective about life
and about
value and about the fragility of life
and all those things and
that's the way i feel about combat i
don't wish it on anybody but i would
wouldn't give it up i wouldn't trade it
for anything
and so i think what you're talking about
is a great way of looking at your past
to say oh
okay um
i had some hardships and i benefited
from those it's basically the same thing
as saying
got bullied good now i know how to
handle myself a little bit better i
didn't have a bunch of friends good now
i feel more comfortable when i'm alone i
think it's the same sort of attitude
in in both those situations
and then as far as
as far as
how people are raised and what you get
it's it's an interesting thing and
probably the only thing i can talk with
any
level of
understanding
of and it's actually a lack of
understanding
is basic seal training
because basic seal training
you would think well you know this
person comes from a hard background
they didn't have much growing up they're
hungry and now they have this
opportunity and they're never gonna quit
or you say oh you know this person went
to a nice private school and they grew
up with a silver spoon in their mouth
and when they get to this harsh
environment they're probably gonna quit
and the fact is that's not true in
either one of those cases some
kids that grew up
in very tough environments
you know working 18 hours a day on a
dairy farm they show up to buds and quit
and and some kids that grew up
you know working 18 hours a day on a
dairy farm they'll never quit and some
kids that grow up with a silver spoon in
their mouth they show up and quit and
some kids that show up with a silver
spoon in their mouth
they never quit
so i think there's some inherent
characteristic of a person that
your environment plays a role
but it can be overcome by determination
and i think you probably have a lot more
control over what you do in your life
than your background does
that is the
i think the genesis of
why i love agency so much why i love
the ability to live your life by
design not by default
the fact that you get to forge whatever
the path is that you want to go forward
like that to me is especially as someone
that like i say maybe grew up felt
feeling a little bit helpless
uh the fact that you realize hang on if
i if i
put this amount of work in and i
dedicate myself and i'm committed and so
on and so forth the fact that you can
come out the other side of that and
realize that it has real world
returns to you is it's phenomenal it's
it's one of the most rewarding most
empowering i hate that word but
you know what i mean like it's kind of
it's one it's just been ruined like
empowering empowerment has been ruined
as a word but it's actually really
useful and i can't use anything else
but it's it's good it's a it's a great
feeling yeah that kind of recognition is
what allows people to move on in life
and take control of their life and make
things happen and you know going back to
your earlier thing about you know if
you're in a relationship with someone
it's not working saying you know what
this isn't working and i'm going to move
on that's a good thing
you have to take ownership and that
doesn't mean ownership meaning i'm
always at fault and therefore i'm gonna
sit here and do nothing it's like oh i'm
at fault for even being in this
relationship with this person i'm gonna
move on
no factor
i've heard you say that you wouldn't be
doing anything that you're doing now
if it wasn't for surfing
how so
well
surfing i started surfing when i was 10
years old i was very lucky that a guy
decided to teach me how to surf a
lifeguard
said hey i'm going to teach you how to
surf
and he did
and yeah that's a huge that
completely directed my life because when
you're looking at all the special
operations unit units to go into
you know there's rangers there's special
forces there's marine corps special
operations there's all these different
things that you can go and do
and one of them is primarily focused on
the water and one of them you can get
stationed either in san diego california
or virginia beach virginia
and it was just such a no-brainer for me
so are you saying that part of your
military career was dictated by where
the good surf was 100
100
and making it through training if i
wouldn't have surfed i
may not have made it through training
because your comfort level in the water
is so high from surfing and you know i
grew up surfing in new england and it's
freezing cold and so the cold water to
me was a joke and the water problems
were relatively easy for me compared to
someone that didn't spend a bunch of
time in the water so
surfing is a is a great thing to have in
your background if you're gonna go
try and be a seal or you know if you
played water polo if you're on the swim
team something that makes you super
comfortable in the water is going to be
highly beneficial and that's probably
the biggest separator in people that
make it in fact it is people that make
it and don't make it if you're
comfortable in the water
you have
a much better chance of making it if
you're let me rephrase that if you're
not comfortable in the water your chance
of making it through seal training is
very small
so people that were
swimmers in high school or whatever
massive massive advantage massive
advantage surfing massive advantage
water polo massive advantage yep i heard
someone say the other day that if they
could
if they could give their kids three
sports to do throughout their uh their
childhood one would be a martial art
that's effective one would be gymnastics
to learn their body in space and one
would be some sort of swimming
water-based event to learn their body in
water i thought
those are those are solid picks right
there seems seems like you're going to
create a bit of a beast of a kid there
yeah yeah it's um
the whole water i mean you see this look
at any event look at crossfit games or
something right and there's always one
guy because there's usually a swim run
bike or a paddleboard run something else
event in there there's always one guy
that
swam in college and you go okay so these
people
train
six hours a day five or six days a week
for
forever and they're the elite of the
elite when it comes to fitness and
homeboy is
he's half the time of the rest of the
field it can't be just due to fitness
it's got to be due to something there's
people with more capacity he'll come
15th in a field of 40 over the overall
but on that event you really do see the
the experience that that someone that
knows how to swim has it's like worlds
apart technique
it's it's technique
just like anything else just like
jiu-jitsu technique will win rock
climbing technique will win
it's interesting that people think you'd
be able to fight without training but
you
why wouldn't you be able to play guitar
without training
it's the same exact thing but no but
when i get really angry
my guitar yeah your guitar comes out
yeah exactly that's that's what people
think same thing with leadership people
think oh well you can't really learn
leadership
it's like no leadership is a skill just
like guitar is a skill there's moves
that are just like playing chords and
people don't understand that and and
that's you know
one of the reasons i am able to that's
why i have a company teaching leadership
because it's like oh you mean you're not
just born with this you mean you're not
just born knowing how to swim you're not
just born knowing how to play guitar and
you're not just born knowing how to lead
you have to learn how to do it and
you can learn how to do it oh you can
absolutely learn as opposed to a fixed
mindset of this is me
this is where i'm at i i don't know
guitar now therefore i'm never going to
know guitar right i'm not a leader now i
don't have creativity you know first
thing that we we spoke about can you
explain to me i've always wanted someone
that knows uh surfing to explain this to
me
let's say that you're surfing a big
swell and you go under
can you explain
how you get out
from underneath a large wave when you're
below the water
i've heard about you swim out sideways
and there's like a particular
well so
in what you're talking about sideways
i'm assuming what you're talking about
is certain breaks have a channel
meaning the waves break in one area but
there's deeper water on either side of
the break and therefore the waves don't
break there and you can see this in any
any of the big famous surf spots or many
most of the big famous surf spots you
can look and you can see there's a boat
sitting here taking pictures of people
that are surfing the waves that boat is
sitting in deep water
and the wave is breaking in shallow
water so generally if you get if you
fall or you're trying to paddle back out
you go into the deep water and you
paddle out and there's no waves breaking
there yeah i thought it was i thought it
was something to do with the fact that
if you were down uh if you were taken
under the water relatively deep below
where the waves were um that trying to
swim either toward land or back is a bad
idea i'm going to guess that oh so what
you're talking about is a is a is a rip
current so a rip current is an area of
the beach where
the the waves are coming in and a rip
current takes all the water that's
coming in towards the towards the beach
and it all kind of funnels in one area
and goes back out to see it's called a
rip current and if you try and swim
directly into the beach
you won't be able to get there because
that rip current can be going
three knots or four knots it can be
strong and you can't swim that fast and
so you'll sit there and swim till
exhaustion and you'll die
so what you do is you swim parallel to
the beach and then you'll drift out a
little further as you swim parallel but
eventually you'll swim out of the rip
current then you can swim into the beach
that's what i meant yep there you go
there's two ways that life seems to be
short to me so one is in the fact that
days
go by pretty quickly and we seem to get
old uh a lot sooner perhaps than we
expect and the other is that tomorrow
is not necessarily promised to us and
that things can end pretty quickly
how do you think people can remind
themselves
of this shortness of life we're very
distracted at the moment there is always
something that can take us away from the
present moment and there are things that
we're moving toward that are in the
future
how can people remind themselves of the
urgency that life has to it
i mean you know for me it's real easy
because i i know that
a lot of a lot of my friends that are
not here
and
that's all i need to that's all i need
to know and
i mean
i think about that every day
so there's no
for me personally there's no
there's no lack of urgency when i wake
up in the morning to think oh don't
worry i got all the time in the world
because i know i don't
and
i'm lucky to be here and i'm going to
try and live in a way that
will at least do justice for my friends
that aren't here
tim kennedy said that he'd looked back
at a
photo of maybe the graduating class that
he was in or certainly some
uh
unit that he was a part of
and he looked at it and he realized that
he was the only person that was left
from that photo
the only one
and
you know it's one of those things it's
kind of like the the um
i got cancer and i i i
sort of didn't want it but i'm glad that
it happened to me because on the other
side of it it kind of feels a little bit
like the same energy as that
that you go well
do i want to lose all of my friends no
absolutely not
have i been able to
like alchemy have i been able to take
something from that like the bullying
thing in later life right have i been
able to
turn that transmute that into something
that i really value
uh and i suppose that that's one of the
ways as well it is about as good of a
forget eulogies forget the service
forget the nice words it's okay
because of what this person did for me
while they were alive now that they've
passed look at how
much more
i'm living look at i mean is there any
better tribute to somebody
definitely makes you appreciate the
sunsets more
we were watching it last night it's very
very nice over here
another thing i've been thinking about
with the shortness of life is the
same 34 and it's only been within the
last maybe two
years or so two to three years
where age has started to actually feel
like a thing now obviously it was a it
was a new age was a thing and but for
most of your 20s what you're doing is
you're becoming
stronger faster smarter
everything continues to get better and
then there's a point kind of like at the
top of a roller coaster where the
inertia comes in and you feel everything
be a bit weightless and he's such a
relatable
recovery from workouts is taking just a
little bit longer than it used to and
injuries are taking a little bit more to
get past and i mean the hangover thing
has been happening since i was like 24
like that just linearly got worse since
i was 24. um
but
there is a point at which you become
kind of aware of your own mortality
uh not in a my friends have died way but
in a
entropy
way
do you have any advice to men that are
getting older and becoming
chronically aware of that yeah lift
weights do jiu jitsu go for run stretch
out eat good stop drinking
it's pretty straightforward if you don't
uh if you don't use it you're gonna lose
it
every day that you
don't do work
you're going backwards and it and it
definitely
will hurt you and it'll show up
you can't get away with what you got
away with when you were 23 you it
doesn't work you you have to
you have to stay ahead of it
i had uh nate zinser dr nate zinser uh
he's a
one of the special forces he was there
uh the mindset coach the psychology
coach
and uh he was telling me i was asking
him what um
what age is it that you can finish
applying for the seal is it 28 25
it's
it's 28 i think it's 28 or 29. and i
asked what what's the reason for there
being an upper bound i mean there's guys
in their 30s that are super fit the guys
in the ufc in the 40s that are super fit
and he said well it's about what the
body can tolerate especially during
selection he was telling me the story
about um one of the
climbing uh rope
climbing
sections
30 feet high over sand and some
20 21 year old kid
fell from the top
flat on his stomach and apparently just
bounced off the floor and got up and
started running he thought actually yeah
if if he was 38 that's a that's a very
different reaction after you've dropped
for 30 feet onto sand yeah the training
is gonna
it's gonna destroy
it destroys kids and so if you're
not ready to recover very quickly it's
going to be a problem and i think you
know are there people that could pull it
off sure there are and there are there
are guys that get waivers that are 32
years old and they're super studs and
they make it but if you
did if you ran the numbers which i'm
sure the navy ran the numbers and is
like oh the i mean quite frankly i just
learned this figure the other day
people that are younger than 20 have
like a five percent chance of making it
through of making through basic seal
training okay because they just don't
have the
the maturity and they might not be
strong enough yet
and i mean i would say the optimum age
is probably like 23 24 you're stronger
[Music]
but i mean i was like i went through
when i was young i was 19 years old
and
you know you were pretty
light as slight compared with now right
when you went through i started i was
174 when i went through
what are you six one six two five eleven
hey okay yep
and
185 when i graduated so i gained like 11
pounds going through sale training
and then
yeah and and
which is you know when you're young i
mean my body is just you know
seeping testosterone you know 19 years
old you're working out all day long with
chicken nuggets yeah chicken nuggets
getting after it just all the food you
can possibly eat
it's it's awesome
[Music]
but it's an abusive training program
it's hard on the body it it trashes guys
for sure i've been hearing uh goggins
stories about
his three times through
i mean he got he was not due to quitting
right i mean his mentality was prepared
to take him further than his body was
twice
um i mean that must be brutal to think
about the fact i often think about this
to do with athletes that get injured how
unfair it is that you get injured
because it's
you
are ready to do the thing and you may
have done everything perfectly
and there's something
something outside of your control in
your physiology that said
no nope
you don't get to do this
yeah the seal training is not fair
at all it's not fair at all
and there's i'm sure there's
good guys that
don't make it because they just
physically can't handle it
that being said the way the program
works
for the most part
if you don't make it it's because you
didn't make it
like they have guys way more people that
ring the bell than have blown out knees
it's it's 80 it's probably 85 90 that
ring out
10 that get some injury that is
incurable
uh because they'll let you heal up they
let guys stay there for a while to heal
up
um
but yeah it's an abusive program
say that with a smile on your face
are there any other
um special forces selections that you're
aware of
that
are uh comparable in terms of the
difficulty
they're all they're all hard they all
have their own tests and they are all
screening out a bunch of people and i've
only been through one
and
they're all they're all different ways
of
beating you up i mean you know for
instance ranger school you don't eat a
lot so people lose 20 pounds during
ranger school
that's preparing them for being
wilderness isolation in the field yep
um
special forces has its own things to
push you so everyone's got their own
little
techniques of getting rid of guys sas is
a lot of orienteering it's a lot of
breaking beacons it's up and down hills
heavy bergen packs yep on your own no
you don't know how much time you've got
they just say do your best
you oh you're trying to let us catch you
you didn't make the time you're out
which i mean you didn't know what the
time was but you didn't know what the
time was but it wasn't fast enough
in seal training you you're not allowed
to wear a watch so how how fast you have
to run as fast as you can at least for
me i had to run this fast training
you're not allowed to wear a watch not a
load of wear watch you know how long
anything is gonna take you don't know
how long you've been swimming for your
only choice is to go hard
that's that's good right we just want
you to go as hard as you can
i did a reality tv show about seven
years ago and um on that they removed
all of our watches before we went in and
all of the clocks of the guys that came
in to change the batteries on our
microphones they changed them all so
they didn't tell the right time the
watches of the drivers the cars that we
got in and we never found out why that
was the case i thought i think it was
because
uh they didn't want us to know when we
were going to bed and waking up because
everyone was excitable and
18 or whatever how long were you in the
field for
i was
in the show for about a month
uh but i mean i'm what were the what
kind of tasks were the timed tasks that
you were that you were executing so uh
unfortunately this isn't as reputable as
doing a reality tv show about
um
armed forces this is a dating show
and
dating like dating like a bachelor like
a male female yes scenario yes jack uh
i'm not equating the two between doing
buds and going on love island um but my
point is that um
i think what they were trying to do was
just uh take the power from the people
that were um
the subjects to the people that were in
control and disorient the the people
that were there now there were actually
it wasn't like a
a challenge thing where people were
having limited food or doing challenges
to stay in and stuff like that it was
exclusively about romance but what
they'd found was that there was
something there must have been something
that they thought that was effective by
doing that and um thankfully i just
didn't have to i didn't have to swim as
much as as you guys did so i came out
the other side of that feeling all right
i'm glad you made it i i did well i mean
like i'm here today it was it was
difficult um
i spoke to michael punky higgs
you know him
seal commander chief master chief
i spoke to him and he's doing some stuff
with psychedelics at the moment um which
i i found absolutely fascinating and he
very carefully
walked me through the um
reason that he he felt he needed i mean
he'd had a gun to his head i think two
or three times separately
uh he was really really struggling and
um
he's doing i think he's in mexico as his
his place where he's doing psychedelic
therapy for veterans what's your what's
your thoughts on on that
uh punky's awesome awesome guy um i'm
glad you said michael punky higgs
because otherwise i just said mike it
would have taken me a minute but yeah
punky's an awesome guy uh i i've never
tried that stuff
and i i've i've definitely talked to a
lot of guys that it's helped out and if
something's gonna help guys out i think
it's
good to go for people to go try it but i
haven't tried it myself and i don't
i don't know i don't know too much about
it um i've had some friends that have
done it uh my friend dakota meyer had
him on the podcast and he talked about
his experiences
i've talked to tim ferriss
a decent amount about it because he's
huge into it at the moment right he is
investing yeah and and before i had
dakota on and i knew dakota and i were
gonna talk about it
i
actually called tim and like took notes
so that i had a better understanding
because i don't know
i don't know
i don't know enough about it to
be able to comment on it for me
it's just being on the outside trying to
trying to
explain or at least share i guess share
the story of people that have utilized
them and it's been helpful for so i
don't know a lot about it was it um was
it dakota that was talking might have
been on rogan about it's a type of patch
some sort of patch or a single time
thing that they maybe do on the neck
yeah that's another thing that's a
that's a uh
stella ganglion block i believe it's
called yep and that's another thing that
people use sounds absolutely wild it's a
single time
thing you do have to get it
you know periodically you know every six
months every year i forgot the date is
but yes that's another thing that's been
very effective for some people
so again i'm i'm i'm not in any position
to talk about this stuff with any uh
with any knowledge whatsoever other than
hey i've i've had some friends that have
done it and they've said it's been
useful it's been helpful
seals were very publicity shy for a long
time and that trend of the the quiet
professional
was uh pretty strong do you ever regret
being
so recognizable or well known
i mean
i spent my whole life
just kind of
being very
you know unrecognizable and and there's
some there's some very nice things about
that
and
you know uh when i
now that i'm now that i'm more
recognizable
you know some of those advantages of
being unrecognizable are gone but
for me the
being able to help people out
has been
worth the
the
pain
and i use that term very loosely worth
the the small inconveniences of
you know being
recognized by by people and most people
that recognize me are cool people that
say hey man
listen your podcast thanks and i say hey
man no problem you know appreciate it so
it's
you know i'm not in some weird scenario
i don't have you know most people that
listen to the podcast are pretty cool
people and that you'd probably want to
meet yeah that i that i would want to
meet and hang out with and they usually
have something positive to say or some
insight that they can give me something
that i missed something that they could
clarify for me so it's all good
it's no factor really i walked down
broadway in nashville with jordan
peterson on a friday night
last year
and
that was uh that was a sight to behold
that was like
i mean he managed to accumulate a queue
of people um to see as he walked down
the street he was who's what's that is
that jordan peterson oh and then
he ended up buying a stetson hat
and doing like the michael jackson thing
like the walk yeah uh in an attempt to
like
get through the crowd
um but yeah i just i thought it was
interesting because you you'd spent all
of this time and and again you had this
culture in the seals of the the quite
professional and stuff
and i was interested in the price that
you know
it's kind of like being in service again
in a weird way right yeah i mean you
know compared with going to war people
coming up to you in the street or
wanting to take a selfie and stuff like
you know not even in the same universe
but my point being that there is still
there's things that you have to put up
with or do
in order to get the message out there
and your
sense is that
it's worth it
yeah it's it's it's fine
i mean again the
amount of feedback that i get from
people that are
that have benefited greatly is well
worth you know any small inconveniences
that i might have in my life it's no
factor what do you think it was about
your task unit that
ended up
it caused it to contain so many
particularly
elite operators i mean it seems to me
like there's been a lot i mean you know
yourself
life uh
chris kyle
uh it was latrell in there as well
no he was not but my point being like
it's
that's like a fairly illustrious list
yeah i mean and
i i don't i'm struggling to see to
remember what word you just used to
describe
the
level of operators but i mean we were
kind of normal kind of a normal task
unit
nothing
spectacular we had a we we got put into
a combat environment that was a target
rich environment and
went hard in in that deployment
and
you know that's that's kind of how it
turned out you know a seal team a seal
platoon
you're gonna get it's it's a bell curve
like any other group and there's some
awesome guys in every seal platoon
there's a bunch of really good guys in
the seal platoon and there's a couple
you know just not so awesome guys in a
sealed platoon but they're gonna they're
gonna do their job too
sometimes and
you know there's
that's the way it is and
you know we we that deployment had a lot
of visibility uh on it because it was
because there was a very kinetic
deployment and
[Music]
um you know we also you know just from a
from a
historical standpoint you know mark lee
was in was it was with us and he was the
first seal killed in iraq and mikey
monsoor was with us and
mikey
you know was was awarded the medal of
honor posthumously
and and so those kind of things sort of
definitely drew the spotlight to
what had happened and and that
deployment what was chris kyle like in
real life
just a awesome funny
guy that was a good patient sniper and
cared about his job
and cared about his family and was a
you know was
was
a good
damn good sniper that would stay on his
gun for a very long time and
you know he was also
very funny very gregarious always doing
pranks
just
just a good a a good guy like like we're
talking about earlier kind of guy you
want to go to war with how did it feel
watching that movie
you know it's it's it's a hollywood
movie and
i i i kind of went into it
with
rudimentary understanding that
this movie's not going to be some
documentary depiction of everything that
happened
yeah they have to take
a guy and take his whole life and take
multiple deployments
and
condense that all down in a very short
time period they got to take a a very
complex
combat situation and bear and and
distill that down into like good guy bad
guy
and
and and that's what they did and and i
you know um also trying to show the
the
sacrifices that the families make and
how hard it is on the families that's
was probably the most important part of
the story
and so it was
you know i watched it and and kind of as
i watched it i kind of understood
those things
and
you know like that was that
to me
the
conversation around
the family of servicemen and service
women families
is is definitely one that
15 years ago i don't remember
thinking about as much
and now is one of the things that's at
the front of my mind that when you have
somebody that goes on
operation and serves it's not just them
that pay the price and it's not just
them and the support units that are out
there and the drivers and the people on
the ground and the fixers and the
translators and stuff there's
a
literal army of people back home as well
that have to pay
sometimes just as high of a price yeah
in some cases higher
um
you know when you when
i'm on deployment i know what's
happening i know what
is going on i know what the risks are
i know what i can do to mitigate those
risks
my my wife my kids were too young to
understand but my wife
she knows what the risks are
she and well let me rephrase that she
doesn't know what the risks are she
doesn't know how we're mitigating risks
she doesn't know
what it's like on the ground
so
it's very easy for someone in the family
to start
you know believing the worst things that
are happening and every you know when
you see that there's a casualty and al
there's two marines killed in the
lombard province or there's four marines
killed in al-anbar province and you know
that the vast majority of those
casualties are taking place in the city
of ramadi which is where your husband is
that can create some that can create
some
that can create some drama in your head
and that can make that deployment worse
for the family at home than it is for
the the guy that's on deployment think
about whenever you've got a missing kid
and what is it that the pair are missing
anybody right
when
the family of that person are doing the
press tour
trying to appeal
the thing that they all say even if it's
been five years i just want to know
because the open loop
of being uncertain about something is
literal torture
and yeah i can imagine that
by not knowing it's not like you're
whatsapp messaging
every couple of hours yeah good just got
to ramadi bit hot here
uh his selfie like that's not that's not
the way that it works nope
nope so they don't know what's going on
and
fear of the unknown is a thing and so
for the families back home it can be
very very difficult for sure
would you ever run for office does that
call to you by the way i i certainly
hope not
[Laughter]
yeah i don't i don't i don't want to get
involved in politics
and
[Music]
you know i don't think it's just a
disgusting sort of
life
and
you know my five friends that are
involved in politics and it just doesn't
seem like
that
uh
doesn't seem like what i'd want to do um
in my life what about running a school
obviously you've got the stuff that you
already do with kids
you have that that foot in the door tim
has got his thing in austin yep
does that call to you yeah and i've i've
got people that are you know again tim
and i talked about this and tim's doing
an awesome thing with his school apogee
cedar park
so and
look at it it's outstanding so
with the warrior kid thing i've got some
uh some irons in the fire on that right
now yep what would you add into or what
would be the uh
are there any big differences that you
think would be made in a school syllabus
typical to what you're aware of at the
moment if
if you were to be the person that was oh
yeah in charge yeah 100 of course
changes to this civilian school yeah
syllabus oh yeah like absolutely what
would you change uh
basic survival skills
right how to start a fire
how to put out a fire
basic
basic trauma medicine how you do first
aid
just those kind of things how you change
the tire on a car
basic plumbing basic electrical like
some life skills that are very
beneficial
working on engines those kind of things
and
yeah those those are things i would add
to the curriculum obviously jiu jitsu
would be in the correct i was going to
say if you were to do that i would be so
interested if everybody was if pe
i don't know what you call it out here
yeah we can't pee
uh if pe was
um
heavily pushed toward learning combat
and learning martial arts
i would be fascinated to know what
happens to bullying rights in schools
yeah
everybody knows that everybody can go
yeah well there's also there's a natural
packing order that gets established and
it is what it is
the thing is
i've said this
jiu jitsu will not only
help you from get getting bullied it
will also prevent you from becoming a
bill bully because when a kid's doing
jiu jitsu they realize oh i'm a little
bit bigger and stronger i can take this
person but there's someone that's bigger
and stronger than me and they can take
me and so it it helps on both both
fronts
what about um
working on movies obviously we've had
cowboy cerrone gina carano they're
people that have moved across into the
movie industry would you be interested
in that as a
writer or maybe even as a
as a person in front of the lens yeah i
mean i've i've got some
some forward motion on
both warrior kid right now and on the
novel that i wrote called final spin so
the both of those are being are moving
forward in the in the movie
arena
that's pretty cool yeah and those it's
take
warrior kid it's taken a while to
find the right people
but
that's that's moving forward and saint
final spin took less i mean final spin
only just came out and it was almost
immediately
was getting requests for a movie
adaptation warrior kid was the same
thing but it took a while to find
the right people and it's a project that
i didn't want to kind of
just haphazardly throw out there to the
world so yeah both those are moving
forward in the
and and
they're going to come how does that feel
as someone who didn't grow up with
no
desire to be a writer
throughout seals throughout brazilian
jiu jitsu and surfing and stuff like
that and then
you just
appear with a
fiction novel and now it's being turned
into a film
how does that feel what does that mean
to you
i mean i have so many stories in my head
that's kind of crazy that's the one that
bubbled to the surface and there's a
bunch more that come up on a daily basis
that it's just a matter of which ones
i'm gonna
take the time to put onto paper
and
you know i i don't know i i
i don't think about that kind of stuff
too much
um
i'm stoked you know it's very cool um
and it's
it's cool i like it it's it's it's gonna
be cool to watch this thing get made
and i'm stoked about it that is a
byproduct the fact that you don't
overthink um
you don't
think too much about the situation
itself i think is a byproduct of someone
that has a lot of forward momentum
i think that when you've just got lots
of things that are happening um you
by necessity you just focus on
whatever's next in front of you yeah
earlier you were talking about thinking
about whether you're gonna be successful
or not and oddly enough i don't really i
don't really think about that i don't
think about
how's this book going to do how's this
is it going to get turned into a movie i
don't think about that
i just kind of go
and like so i guess yes i agree with you
you're the forward momentum piece i'm
kind of moving forward and people that
work with me they know that i'm like on
to the next thing all right hey cool
that thing's that thing's got some
trajectory it's going in the right
direction cool i'm gonna go on to the
next thing and and keep moving forward
i spoke to huben a couple of weeks ago
and i brought up with him about the fact
that um he's got tattoos that
very few people have have seen although
there are photos on the internet there's
one of him in an uh
octopus t-shirt
looking like this um
have you got any tattoos right thinking
that you've got one what what is it what
does it mean i i got a tattoo when i was
a kid like you know i was in the
hardcore scene and
and
you know
we all were getting tattoos and and so
yeah i got a tattoo it's like just a
kind of a random design on my back
uh no real
it's kind of half finished and it's kind
of dumb but would you ever finish it off
or you just i don't care not bothered
that well i guess it is literally behind
you yeah yeah it's literally behind me
and i think one of my daughters said
they usually get that thing finished i'm
like yeah i'm not gonna miss i'm not
gonna miss three days of jiu-jitsu to
let a tattoo heal up so that is it's not
happening
so i know that you're a fan of the uh
thomas soul quote where he says there's
no solutions only trade-offs and this is
something
in a roundabout way that same concept is
probably one of the most meaningful
things i've learned this year
what does that quote mean to you or how
have you how have you
reflected on that
well especially from a leadership
perspective
that's kind of where i talked about it
for the first time how the heck did you
hear that quote from me that's i don't
know when i've said that i guess i could
do some podcasts about it but
yeah it's a it's it's very helpful to
people's mindsets i think and that's
when i when i talked about that it was
primarily to help people see
that
you're looking for a full-on solution to
this problem and there's probably not a
full-on solution that's going to satisfy
every
every aspect of this scenario
so what you have to do instead is you
have to look for what what's the
trade-off going to be i'm going to win a
little bit here i'm going to lose a
little bit there but overall it's going
to move me in the right direction i
think it's a good thing to understand as
opposed to going through life thinking
that you're going to find a 100 solution
because it's not going to exist so
you're going to have to make trade-offs
in life
douglas murray came on the show and he
was talking about this
story from christopher hitchens where
hitch told him that in life we have to
choose our regrets
and what he meant by that was the fact
that
opportunity cost demands
that you're going to have regrets and
i'd always thought that regrets were a
bug not a feature of life i didn't
realize that they were baked into the
literal fabric of how we exist so you
could make the perfect decision
and still look back and have regrets
about not making the other ones simply
because of that open loop that we were
talking about before yeah you don't know
what the other thing could have been i
said okay so well that's interesting
that
regrets are a feature not a bug what
does it mean that you need to choose
them
okay well
given the fact that regrets are baked
into the fabric of life
when you're making a decision one of the
things that you need to consider is
which of these regrets can i live with
and which of these regrets can i not
live with
and that there's no solutions only
trade-offs thing speaks to the same
energy
100 percent do you own a house yes
so when you're the a real estate agent
told me this years and years ago
when you're looking at a house there's
gonna be shortfalls
there's gonna be problems with the house
that you're looking at
and whether it's gonna be even if it's
the perfect house well that means it's
gonna cost a ton so that's the trade-off
that you're gonna make and so what you
have to do is you have to break down
like what you just said hey listen i
wanted a bigger yard but this one has a
huge garage
i'm going to go with it you just got to
figure out those trade-offs there's no
solutions you're not going to get the
perfect house until you build one
and even when we build one guess what
you're going to look at it when you're
done and you're going to say i should
have moved this wall
24 inches to the west
right it's it'll it'll each up
talk to me about your uh approach with
long-term plans because i've heard you
mentioned that uh
real long-term plans
are something that you don't necessarily
optimize for you seem to optimize a
little bit more for optionality and for
kind of a medium-term thing what's your
thinking around that yeah i don't know
what i'm gonna be doing in five years
people what are you what's your five
year plan i have no idea what my five
year plan is because i don't know what
opportunities are going to arise i don't
know what things i'm gonna fail at i
don't know what mistakes i'm gonna make
so where how am i gonna sit here and
tell you where i'm gonna be in five
years i i can't
and if i did i'd probably be shutting
off some opportunities that are there
because i'm too close-minded and focused
on some
five-year plan
so
i make iterative decisions about things
i move a little bit in some direction i
test i get the feedback from it was it
good was it bad
should i put more resources toward it or
not and then as time goes by i've either
moved significantly in that direction or
i've realized it's a dead end and i'm
going to move away
it was it was more convenient
a year ago when i'd say five years ago i
didn't have a podcast i didn't have a
book i didn't have any that wasn't
didn't have anything really
that was five years ago so my five year
plan if you would six years ago my five
year plan would have been like oh i
guess i'll be training jiu jitsu and i
would be training jiu jitsu and surfing
and hanging out with my family working
with life probably doing national um
front but maybe a slightly bit bigger
maybe not even yeah i mean i don't know
yeah we we we didn't jump in and invest
some huge amount of money into ashland
front no we started hey does anyone want
to learn this stuff oh yeah it looks
like they do oh yeah it looks like a lot
of people do oh looks like it's very
beneficial to them oh they're telling
all their friends at other companies
that they should do this stuff so they
can get better
and that whole way down the path yes
we'll spend more time we'll invest more
into it we'll write a book about it cool
that made sense
so
that's what that's what i have to take
the the approach with everything what
opportunities are going to knock on my
door today what opportunities have i
started that are going to close tomorrow
i don't know so i don't spend i don't
invest a lot of
time and energy trying to predict where
i'm going to be in five years when i
don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
i i really resonated with that i really
like it because
especially in the online productivity
world you know you should break down the
25-year plan into
five-year blocks into one-year sprints
into quarterly goals or whatever and
it's just never resonated with me it's
never resonate it doesn't appeal to my
nature it doesn't appeal to the way that
life is
by design
unpredictable and you don't know what
skills you're going to acquire what
setbacks or advantages are going to come
your way
and that was you it was you're one of
the first people i've heard who's really
succinctly putting together is look i
don't have and you're someone that if
people would think jocko's the kind of
guy with the plan right you don't go
into battle without a plan yeah well
yeah but the entire war is something
that requires us to respond as it occurs
yeah look at the mistakes we've made
well america has made as a country in
war why because we had a long-term
strategy that didn't make sense
and guess what no one was willing to say
hey this long-term strategy we've got is
not working we need to make some
adjustments and we need to do it now
instead nope
ignore those numbers ignore the the
feedback loop that we're getting just
press forward with this strategy that
we're on doesn't it doesn't work so i
don't want to have you have to go into
battle with an idea of where you want to
get to and then you as you start moving
in that direction you've got to say oh
that wasn't what i thought it was going
to be we need to make some adjustments
that's the
discipline and creativity
spectrum coming up again it is indeed
looking from the outside as somebody
that's
black belt in brazilian jiu jitsu the
stuff that you're doing with origin
bringing manufacturing back to the us
writing books books being turned into
screenplays and movies and stuff like
that and everything else that you do
that from the outside can look like
something which is
uh
incredibly
desirable as a position to get in
one thing that i've learned over the
last few years especially since spending
more time around the people that are
successful and have accolades and stuff
is that often there's prices that they
pay
for getting to this stage that they're
at
that the people who
want to be there
wouldn't end up paying
so um
what i've come to believe is that a lot
of the time people have
very very uh high bars and challenges
that they need to get past i'm
interested in what the
price is
that you have to pay in order to sort of
be
jocker wellington on a daily basis
work
work
a lot of work
you know when uh when you're
watching tv or you're
[Music]
you know looking at instagram or you're
you know going out for
dinner
on a date and you go to a movie
i'm not doing that
i'm reading a book i'm getting ready for
a podcast i'm writing something i'm
preparing for something um
talking to a client i'm designing
something i'm thinking about a new
supplement like it's just
just it's it's it's just kind of all the
time and so
this is a guy asked me the other day are
you working more now than you were when
you were in the seal teams and the
answer is 100 yes i'm working harder now
you know i'm well i should say i'm
working more because i'm working
more more time
no weekends
um
no weekends no evenings really
luckily for me
i like what i do i was going to say so
would you even want that you know would
you want
to
spend an afternoon on the couch watching
netflix is that something after a very
long time of driving discipline
is that a desire that you have any
longer
to sit on the couch and watch netflix
yeah
i mean not that's not that's not super
i'm not super stoked on that yeah that's
my point uh yeah you've managed to align
what you want
and what you want to want
they're not sitting on top of each other
right yeah and i i also don't do a lot
of what i don't want to do and my
partner echelon front life babin pointed
this out to me like a year ago
he just said
he said you know you've oh you're really
good he was doing some stuff that he
didn't want to be doing
and you know whether it was
administrative stuff
and you know he said you know i've got
to do this and i've got to do so why are
you doing that
and he said well what do you mean i said
get someone else to do that
and then you know a week later he's
talking he goes you know i was thinking
about what you said you're really good
at not doing what you don't want to do
and i am good at doing i'm i am good at
not doing what i don't want to do
i mean
administrative stuff stuff like that i
don't do any of it i don't do any of it
do i have an accountant does an
accountant cost me a lot of money yes
they do do i worry about it nope not in
a single bit not in the slightest way
don't worry about it at all and i don't
have to deal with it
and
my taxes are getting done you know
that's a lot that's a crazy amount of
work and effort i don't do any of it
logistics
for
my online store do i do i don't do any
ad
i don't do any of that
i don't touch that stuff so all the
stuff that what i get to do what i like
to do
the weird thing is it is a lot and and
and mo it's it's going to be it's
challenging for people to do
it's challenging for people to do it's
challenging
it's challenging
you know
you know my wife
she's like
you know i said well
that's not
i i said you know she'll say like what
about what about this and i'm like oh
i'm not gonna do that and she says
you're not normal
you know and i said okay fair enough
she doesn't think i'm she doesn't think
i'm normal and i think she's probably
right i
fear she may be right as well yeah
so what's the principle there that that
people could take away is it to try and
outsource the things that you don't want
to do especially let's say that it's
someone that's growing a business or
that is um beginning to get themselves
to this stage where they have the
resources to be able to do this
as quickly as possible
give away the things that you don't like
to do to people who can do them yeah and
and there's certain things that only you
can do
yes do you do those things yes and let
other people do things that other people
can do
and and and look i'm i'm also you know
if you want to get straight business
business tactical i tell people all the
time
you know you you keep things small and
you let the demand signal increase and
you grow as the demand signal increases
and
as opposed to walk
i'm not i don't jump in and say oh i
don't like doing paperwork and i've got
a business that i've had for three
months so i'm going to hire someone as a
as a cfo to run my accounting right now
no i'm doing that stuff i'm doing that
stuff until
we have enough income to comfortably say
yeah we can get someone else to do this
now and i can then focus on what i'm
good at so i've done that with all my
businesses start small and grow as the
demand signal is there grow
and you know i've done things that did
didn't work and luckily i didn't invest
a bunch of time and effort into them
because hey
i'm
i'm going to be wrong a lot and so just
because i think something is cool
doesn't mean other people are going to
think it's cool
i happen to like some random thing and
some people might not or a lot of people
might not like it so i'm not going to
overly invest in something that that
people might not want at all
thinking about the stuff that you can
afford to outsource and the things that
you can't i think a good heuristic is
what you just said there so what are the
things that only you can do only you can
do your podcast only i can do my podcast
precisely only you can write your book
books et cetera uh another one that i
learned the other day from laila hormozy
is a lot of the time let's say that
someone's got a company a sales company
selling software rit or whatever one of
the first people that they'll bring on
is a salesperson and then they'll begin
to do operations and she said well hang
on
that's the thing that brings the money
in
that's the thing
that
gives fuel to the engine which you're
hoping will drive everything else so i
do think that there's another element
that i learned from her which is
do not outsource the thing that drives
the revenue
the thing that drives the revenue must
be protected at all costs and if that
thing is you
and another element that links back to
what you just said there if that thing
is your motivation
how can we protect the motivation
well my motivation is waning to do the
thing to write the book to do the
podcast to give the speeches whatever
because of the amount of administration
okay let's lean into that even more
there's that's the point of highest uh
leverage for us
get that blockage out of the way yeah
yeah and i have
all kinds of people that do all the
stuff that i'm either a not good at or b
don't want to do
which is beautiful
you know it's a beautiful thing that's
decentralized command it's the fourth
law of combat leadership you know like
hey how
well what's going on in
we have five factories right now at
origin usa
right where are they
three in maine two in north carolina
so that's an incredible amount of
logistics and and
i mean just leadership that's going on
inside those
and
the technical aspect of weaving cloth
and sewing and setting up lines for
production that's incredible amount of
work and effort and knowledge that i
don't have any expertise in whatsoever
guess what i have a team that does i
have people that are awesome
and so
that's what's going on echelon front we
have
scores of clients
and they need help in leadership i can't
teach them all guess what i have a whole
team of people that has their own
experiences and they're out there every
single day teaching clients the the
leadership lessons that we know jocko
fuel the same thing you were asking me
earlier like what goes into making these
things oh am i giving strategic guidance
about what i want a hundred percent am i
taste sampling which by the way there's
a good example of something that didn't
work
you know the first we made an energy
drink the first version of the energy
drink
was based on my taste buds well my taste
buds since i don't drink a lot of sweets
the first version that we made
was not very sweet at all to me it
tasted like
maple syrup practically
but
we i had to open my mind and get
feedback and people were like no
actually this doesn't taste good okay
well then let's change it we just
changed we just changed every single
flavor starting now
but that took
that took trial and error of me saying
wait a second i love the way this tastes
but
seven out of ten people think yeah it's
okay three out of ten people say this
doesn't taste good at all that's
that's not a that's not a success
you got to have 10 out of 10 people say
this freaking tastes delicious and look
you've got different flavors and maybe 9
out of 10 love
all the flavors and there's one that oh
they don't like this one but
i've got to take that feedback
and and adjust
to
what i'm hearing but that's an example
of hey we went down this road of this
certain flavor
and a flavor system that was based on my
taste
which is why i i know that i have to
open my mind and take other opinions and
listen to what other people have to say
and now we've got tastes that
are delicious and universally delicious
and so now we can kind of go hard and
getting it out there because before
there's a risk of hey if how many times
are you gonna get someone to try a drink
one time if it tastes like junk they're
not getting it again
so now we've got tastes that are
delicious and now people yep try it now
we're now we can win on taste which is
awesome we're already winning on
efficacy
and and health
but you gotta you gotta win on all
fronts so now we can win on taste too
what's coming up next what have you got
for the rest of the year that's coming
up that you're excited about or
interested in
probably one of the biggest things is
we've got a a hunt line coming out from
origin so we're making
a full
line of hunting clothing hunting apparel
from the base layer all the way out to
the outer jacket
so that's been a huge undertaking
and
it's
very aggressive it was very aggressive
what do you mean
trying to get that done in a short
period of time it was very aggressive
and the reason we were able to do is
because everything's in america the
reason we're able to do is because we're
able to
literally making a make a design change
and have it 15 minutes later for testing
you can't do that when you're working
with an overseas company it's impossible
it's
at a minimum if you're
flying it it's going to take three four
days four or five days to get back it's
got to get in line you don't control the
line it's it's a travesty but we were
able to because we're all manufactured
here
and the material that we're using from
here
so we don't even have to wait for some
material to ship from overseas
everything is 100 american-made so
that was a huge undertaking we're
starting to get to that point where
i think i'm getting my first uh set of
the kit here in another week and then
it'll be going into production so
that's pretty cool
you know we have a an online training
academy so
the leadership thing again you know we
talked about leadership being a skill
just like you can't go to the gym in one
time and get in shape where you can't
change jujitsu one time and now you can
defend yourself or you can't pick up a
guitar one time it's the same thing with
leadership you can't just
sit through
one seminar or read one book and go okay
cool i've got i mean imagine if you
picked up a book on guitar
and you read it
and now you thought you were gonna be
able to play guitar or you read a book
about basketball and now look you would
get the concepts down you would
understand what you're gonna be working
to toward but it's a legitimate skill
that you have to employ in scenarios to
get better at
and so
in order to in order to make that happen
and it was
again a little bit of a blessing from
covid we had created an online platform
for a client that had 157 000 employees
worldwide and they wanted us to train
all their employees and so i said hold
on a minute
because that would have basically been
the dedication of the entire team at
echelon front to make that happen
traveling
and so we had created before covet we
created an online training platform
and then as that
as covid hit
we immediately said okay looks like
we're doing this stuff virtually and
what was beautiful was the entire world
was
was made to do virtual interaction
whether it was talking i i knew in
easter i had
whatever easter dinner with my parents
via
a skype call or zoom call or whatever
and i said yep this is this is the norm
now everyone's to understand the
capability the the benefits of being
able to utilize video interaction
because before that before covet it was
it was rare i mean how many video calls
did you do before kovid apart from the
podcast he was my input from that uh up
until kovid video podcasting was seen as
a second-rate thing to do right
don't get me wrong i would much rather
sit down but especially as a fledgling
creator coming up and didn't have joe
rogan money right right so i couldn't
have a nice studio or fly guest out or
do whatever um so for me that was how i
was competing
then everybody had to do yep yep you you
want to keep your show going you want to
keep publishing
completely flattened the field right
which meant that what are we competing
on now oh we're competing on the quality
of the conversation we're not competing
on how fancy the studio is yep
well that's interesting and so has that
happened to you and as it happened to
every family in america that suddenly
realized they were going to utilize and
they understood the technology now
because there's a technology barrier so
now at echelon front we said okay great
now we can
now we can train people on a much more
regular basis we can offer them so so we
made
extreme ownership.com which is an online
training platform for leadership and for
life because if you're that's not just
for corporate that's also people can go
do that themselves it's individuals and
it's individuals this is the thing that
you know part of the thing that people
people need to understand is if you're a
human and you interact with other human
beings you're in a leadership position
it doesn't matter if you're the if
you're a front-line worker and you're
not in charge of any other people but
guess what you're interacting with your
peers you're interacting and you have to
lead your boss
you have to be able to lead your boss
your boss doesn't know what's happening
in the field your boss doesn't know what
time that concrete should be poured your
boss doesn't know what what time uh
those those that those forms need to be
set up by it doesn't know that
you have to lead your boss in that right
direction you have to lead your peers in
the right direction you have to lead
your family in the right direction
you have to even if you're you by
leading your family that means putting
your ego in check and listening to what
your kids have to say so there's
everybody's a leader
and
once people understand that there's so
much they can get out of
actually learning leadership skills
so that's been that's been pretty cool
on the echelon front
side so that's the origin side that's
the echelon front side the jocko fuel
side again we rearranged these flavors
we've
so that's been huge and and the rest of
the supplement line is
just it's just
making high quality stuff
and not cutting corners
and we're look in the beginning when
you're doing that
it's hard right because you think
well wouldn't it be just easier if we
did this wouldn't it be couldn't we just
cut this couldn't we use a little less
of this
this uh protein that's more expensive
it's expensive type of sweetener right
whatever
and so you want to make those cuts early
on and
we didn't and and look
quite frankly when my name is on the
freaking label i i can't i can't just
cut corners
but now people recognize that they
recognize that when they buy something
from jackal fuel it's as good as it's as
good as you can get it's the best
quality stuff that you can get so
that's starting to
starting to take hold and so that's been
that's been great to see as well
jacqueline ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
stuff that you're doing where should
they go
jocko.com
chucco i appreciate you thank you thanks
man appreciate it what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace